This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In May 2007, an artist living in Chicago moved into a new place. It was a small room with white walls. The interior design was minimalist. There was a bed, a desk, a computer, a lamp, and a paintball gun. A fixed to the gun was a webcam. It live-streamed the room to the internet. anyone could look in and anyone could take control of the gun, aim and fire.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2007年5月，一位住在芝加哥的艺术家搬进了一个新地方。那是一个白墙的小房间。室内设计采用极简主义。里面有一张床、一张桌子、一台电脑、一盏台灯和一把漆弹枪。枪上固定着一个网络摄像头。它将房间的实况直播到互联网上，任何人都可以查看，任何人都可以控制这把枪，进行瞄准和射击。
At all hours of the day and night, the paintball gun would spring to life and begin shooting yellow pellets into the room. Some hit the walls or the furniture. Some hit the artist. I was shot at 70,000 times, and I received 80 million hits on the internet from 128 countries. Wafa Bilal spent one whole month in the room, targeted tens of thousands of times by random strangers around the world. Why would he choose to do this? Wafa was born and raised in Iraq.
在白天和黑夜的每一个小时里，这把漆弹枪都会突然启动，开始向房间里发射黄色漆弹。有些击中了墙壁或家具。有些击中了这位艺术家。我被击中了7万次，并在互联网上获得了来自128个国家的8,000万次点击量。瓦法·比拉尔在房间里度过了整整一个月，成了世界各地无数陌生人恶作剧的目标。他为什么会选择这样做？瓦法在伊拉克出生长大。
He came to the U.S. in the early 90s. I live this duality of living in two places. One is a comfort zone of the United States, and the other one is the conflict zone in Iraq where my family, friends live. In 2004, Wafa says one of his brothers was killed in an airstrike. One of my brother, Haji, was killed in air to ground a missile. And I didn't know what to do.
他在90年代初来到美国。我体验着这种生活在两个地方的双重性。一个是美国的舒适区，另一个是我家人和朋友居住的伊拉克冲突区。瓦法说，2004年，他的一个兄弟在一次空袭中丧生。我的一个兄弟哈吉在空对地导弹袭击中丧生。我不知道该怎么办。
Wafa is a performance artist, and he wanted to engage others in the conversation that was running through his mind. Three years after his brother's death, he got an idea. I said, I want to lock myself in the gallery space for 30 days and I'm going to build a robot connected to the internet and the robot shoots
瓦法是一名行为艺术家，他想让其他人参与到他脑海中不断浮现的对话中。在他兄弟去世三年后，他萌生了一个想法。我说，我想把自己锁在画廊空间30天，我要造一个连接到互联网的机器人，这个机器人会发射
paintball and viewers online could direct that gun and shoot at me. It's day 16. My body is just getting weak by the day. I thought I felt better.
漆弹，网上的观众可以指挥那把枪向我射击。今天是第16天。我的身体一天比一天虚弱。我以为我感觉好些了。
As the days went by, Wafa started to feel crushed by the experience. It's late night. I feel extremely tired. But I'm afraid to go to bed. In some ways, Wafa was attempting to do what civil disobedience movements around the world have done. He was deliberately putting himself in harm's way in order to draw attention to a problem and affect change.
随着日子一天天过去，瓦法开始感到被这段经历压垮了。已经是深夜了。我觉得非常疲惫。但我害怕去睡觉。在某些方面，瓦法试图做世界各地的公民抗命运动所做的事情。他故意让自己陷入险境，以引起人们对某个问题的关注并推动变革。
I have United States, I have Denmark, I have Ireland, I have the UK, I have France again, Canada. So it's not one place. It is almost a global shooting. And I don't know. Somebody said, imagine an entire nation living like this. Why did strangers who knew nothing about Wafa take it upon themselves to hurt him? Do technology in modern life and the anonymity they offer make us less caring as human beings? On today's show, building empathy in a connected and confrontational world.
我有美国、丹麦、爱尔兰、英国、法国还有加拿大。所以这不是一个地方。这几乎是一场全球性的枪击。而且我不知道。有人说，想象一下整个国家都过着这样的生活。为什么对瓦法一无所知的陌生人会自作主张去伤害他？科技和现代生活以及它们提供的匿名性是否让我们作为人类变得不那么有同情心了？在今天的节目中，我们将在一个互联且对抗的世界中建立同理心。
Jamil Zaki is a psychologist at Stanford University. He's the author of the book, The War for Kindness, Building Empathy in a Fractured World. Jamil, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. You have a very powerful story about how you came to be interested in the subject of empathy. Tell me about your parents, where they are from, how they met, what they went through, and what you learned from the experience. So it turns out that in the early 1970s, Washington State University in Pullman had a program where they granted full scholarships for graduate studies to students from the world's poorest nations. My mother received the scholarship from Peru, and my father did not receive a scholarship, but nonetheless came to Washington State from Pakistan.
贾米尔·扎基是斯坦福大学的心理学家。他是《善良的战争：在一个四分五裂的世界中建立同理心》一书的作者。贾米尔，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。你有一个非常引人入胜的故事，讲述了你是如何对同理心这个话题产生兴趣的。跟我讲讲你的父母，他们来自哪里，他们是怎么认识的，他们经历了什么，以及你从这段经历中学到了什么。原来在20世纪70年代初，位于普尔曼的华盛顿州立大学有一个项目，他们为来自世界上最贫穷国家的学生提供研究生全额奖学金。我母亲获得了来自秘鲁的奖学金，而我父亲没有获得奖学金，但尽管如此，他还是从巴基斯坦来到了华盛顿州。
So they traveled from Lima and Lahore, these two massive cities, to the sleepy town of Pullman, where they fell in love. When I think about my parents, I think the biggest thing that they had in common was their sense of foreignness in the U.S. They sort of took comfort in each other in a place that neither of them understood. But as they grew more comfortable with the U.S. and more acclimated to it, they grew less comfortable with each other. And they divorced. They started splitting up when I was eight, but didn't finish until I was 12. And theirs was a long and acrimonious split.
于是他们从利马和拉合尔这两个巨大的城市，来到了沉睡的普尔曼小镇，并在那里坠入爱河。当我想到我的父母时，我认为他们最大的共同点是他们在异国他乡的陌生感。在一个谁都不理解对方的地方，他们从彼此身上寻求慰藉。但随着他们对美国越来越习惯，越来越适应，他们对彼此却越来越不习惯了。于是他们离婚了。我8岁时他们开始分居，直到我12岁才彻底办完。他们的分开是一段漫长而痛苦的过程。
And I am their only child. And so a lot of my childhood was spent kind of bouncing around between their houses. And it really felt like I was bouncing between parallel universes, because their priorities and values and fears are really as far apart as their hometowns. So I would often feel confused. You know, as a small child, I would try to, when I was with my mom, figure out the rules that governed her heart and mind and make them true for myself. But then when I would go to my dad's house, those same rules would stop working.
我是他们的独生子。所以我的童年很大一部分时间都是在他们的房子之间辗转反dering。感觉就像在平行宇宙之间穿梭，因为他们的首选项、价值观和恐惧确实和他们的家乡一样相去甚远。所以我经常感到困惑。你知道，作为一个小孩子，当我和妈妈在一起时，我会试图找出主宰她内心和思想的规则，并让它们对我自己也成立。但当我去了我爸爸家时，同样的规则就失效了。
And it was just very confusing. And it felt, I think, to all three of us, like I would really have to be. have to choose one of my parents and give up on really knowing the other. But I knew that I had to try for all of our sake. So I did, and I kind of kept working at it and eventually got better, learned to tune myself to my parents' different frequencies. And that kind of saved me as a kid. I think empathy saved me. Not because it's easy, it was work. I always think of my parents' divorce as an empathy gym for me that forced me to work out my ability. to care about and understand other people.
这真的很让人困惑。而且我想，对我们三个人来说，这感觉就像我真的必须去。必须在父母之间做出选择，并放弃真正了解另一方的机会。但我知道为了我们所有人的利益，我必须尝试。所以我做了，我一直在努力，最终做得越来越好，学会了调整自己以适应父母不同的频率。那种经历在某种程度上拯救了我，作为一个孩子。我认为同理心拯救了我。不是因为它容易，这需要付出努力。我总是把父母的离婚看作是我的同理心健身房，它强迫我锻炼自己去关心和理解其他人的能力。
And you, as you've said, described this as an empathy, Jim. Were there times when you failed to show them empathy? I mean, I must imagine that as a small child, it must have been very difficult in many ways to comprehend what was happening and why these two adults were fighting over you and each was demanding that you see things from their point of view. Oh, absolutely. I mean, one of the big realizations for me as a kid was realizing that both of them
正如你所说，你将这描述为一个同理心，健身房。有没有那么几次，你没能向他们表现出同理心？我的意思是，我一定可以想象，作为一个小孩子，在很多方面要理解正在发生的事情，以及为什么这两个成年人为争夺你而争吵，并且每个人都要求你从他们的角度看待问题，这一定非常困难。哦，当然。我的意思是，作为一个孩子，我最大的感悟之一就是意识到他们两个人都
were in pain. I think as a child, it's very easy to focus on your own perspective and what you're going through and to blame others, especially adults. I think when I realized that my parents were both struggling, just like I was, it actually made me feel kinship towards them and made it easier to understand that I could connect with both of them, in fact, because what we were going through wasn't that different. Talk a little bit about the benefits of empathy. There's been a lot of work that looks at what happens when people receive empathy from their partners, for example, or from their doctors? Oh, yeah. I mean, in many cases, empathy benefits all parties involved. So, for instance, patients of empathic doctors are more satisfied with their care, but are also more likely to
都在痛苦中。我想作为小孩子，非常容易关注你自己的视角和你的经历，并责怪他人，尤其是成年人。我想当我意识到我的父母都在挣扎，就像我一样，它实际上让我对他们产生了亲切感，并让我更容易理解，事实上我可以与他们两人建立联系，因为我们正在经历的事情并没有那么大不同。聊聊同理心的好处吧。有很多研究探讨了当人们从他们的伴侣或医生那里获得同理心时会发生什么？哦，是的。我的意思是，在许多情况下，同理心对所有相关方都有益。例如，拥有富有同理心的医生的患者对他们的护理更满意，而且也更有可能
follow doctors' recommendations, which is important for things like preventative care. And spouses of empathic partners are happier in their marriages. But one thing that I think people don't realize as much is that people who experience empathy for others also benefit. It's not just receiving it, but giving it helps us too. Feeling empathy for others reduces our stress and adolescents who are able to pick out other people's emotions accurately are better adjusted during middle school.
遵循医生的建议，这对于预防保健等事情很重要。而拥有富有同理心的伴侣的夫妻在婚姻中更幸福。但有一点我认为人们意识得没那么多，那就是对他人体验到同理心的人也能受益。不仅是接受它，付出它也能帮助我们。对他人感同身受可以减轻我们的压力，而那些能够准确挑出他人情绪的青少年在初中阶段适应得更好。
Now, parents everywhere recognize the value of empathy. We have courses and classes that try and teach children empathy. I came by this clip on Sesame Street featuring the actor Mark Ruffalo and the character Murray. Take a listen to the clip. Murray, did I tell you about that time when I lost my favorite teddy bear? Oh, no. It was... This is very sad.
现在，各地的父母都认识到了同理心的价值。我们有课程和班级试图教导儿童同理心。我在《芝麻街》上看到了这个片段，其中有演员马克·鲁法洛和角色默里。听听这个片段。默里，我跟你说过我弄丢我最喜欢的泰迪熊的那次经历吗？哦，没有。那是……这非常令人难过。
Did you love that teddy bear? I loved that teddy bear. I can imagine exactly how you feel. It's really sad for you. feeling it makes you want to cry like this. It was sad. It was so sad. But you know what?
你喜欢那只泰迪熊吗？我爱那只泰迪熊。我能想象出你的感受。这对你来说真的很伤心。感同身受会让你想这样哭泣。这很难过。太难过了。但你知道吗？
What? You know what empathy is. I do? That was empathy. What? You could understand how I was feeling, exactly how I was feeling and understood it. That's empathy. I get it now.
什么？你知道什么是同理心吗？我吗？那就是同理心。什么？你能理解我的感受，确切地理解我的感受并理解它。这就是同理心。我现在懂了。
Jamil, you've used a similar kind of scenario to explain empathy. Someone's talking with a friend. The friend gets a phone call. Walk me through the rest of that scenario. three components that you've identified that make up empathy? Yeah, so again, imagine that you're sitting with the friend having lunch and they receive a phone call and whatever the person on the other side of the line says makes them visibly upset. You don't know what's wrong, but your friend starts to cry and it's obvious that something is wrong. Well, as you see this, a bunch of things
贾米尔，你曾用过类似的情景来解释同理心。有人在和朋友聊天。朋友接了一个电话。带我了解一下该情景的其余部分。你确定的构成同理心的三个要素是什么？是的，再次想象一下，你正和朋友坐在一起吃午饭，他们接到一个电话，电话那头的人不管说了什么，都让他们明显心烦意乱。你不知道出了什么问题，但你的朋友开始哭泣，很明显出了什么问题。好吧，当你看到这一幕时，一堆事情
might happen inside you. First, you might become upset yourself, sort of vicariously catching their feeling. That's what psychologists often call. emotional empathy. You might also try to figure out what's wrong, what they're feeling and why. That's what we call cognitive empathy. And if you're a good friend at least, you probably will feel concern for what they're going through and a desire for their well-being to improve. That's what psychologists call empathic concern or compassion. And even though these pieces of empathy sometimes go together, they also split apart in interesting ways. So for instance, brain systems support emotional and cognitive empathy and empathic concern. And different groups of
可能会在你内心发生。首先，你可能会自己也感到心烦意乱，可以说是间接地传染了他们的情绪。这就是心理学家经常称之为的。情绪同理心。你可能还会试图弄清楚出了什么问题，他们的感受是什么以及为什么。这就是我们所说的认知同理心。如果你至少是一个好朋友，你可能会对他们正在经历的事情感到关心，并渴望他们的福祉得到改善。这就是心理学家所说的同理心关怀或同情。尽管同理心的这些部分有时会结合在一起，但它们也会以有趣的方式分离开来。例如，大脑系统支持情感和认知同理心以及同理心关怀。不同的群体
people struggle with different flavors of empathy. That's fascinating. It's almost like these are different muscle groups and you need all the muscle groups to be functioning to, in some ways, actualize your full capacity for empathy. I love that analogy. Yeah, that's a perfect way of putting it. At the same time that parents and books and motivational speakers and fate tradition, cite the value of empathy, many of us are living in ways that isolate us from the people around us. Among people 18 to 34, for example, 10 times as many people live alone today, as did in 1950. I asked Jamil whether there's a link between going solo and the amount of empathy we feel for others. It's hard to say, you know, and I do want to be clear that in looking at any
人们在不同类型的同理心上挣扎。这太迷人了。这就像这些是不同的肌肉群，你需要所有的肌肉群都能正常运作，才能在某种程度上实现你对同理心的全部潜能。我喜欢这个比喻。是的，这是一种完美的说法。在父母、书籍、励志演讲者和传统习俗都在赞美同理心的价值的同时，我们许多人的生活方式却将我们与周围的人隔离开来。例如，在18至34岁的人群中，今天独居的人数是1950年的10倍。我问贾米尔，独居与我们对他人感到的同理心之间是否存在某种联系。很难说，你知道，我确实想明确一点，在观察随时间推移的任何
demographic trends over time and trying to link them to empathy to decline, we're necessarily speculating, right? There's no way to run an experiment where you have history occur multiple times and fiddle with different pieces of it to see what causes a decline in empathy. But certainly, you know, you can point to big shifts in the way that people live. And one of them is that we're becoming more urban and more solitary. And when we interact with people, it's often in more transactional ways, right? Sort of some of the regular that used to bring us into contact with other people often are giving way to more solitary pursuits. So there's some evidence, for instance, that anonymous interactions do not favor
人口统计趋势并试图将它们与同理心下降联系起来时，我们必然是在推测，对吧？没有办法进行这样一项实验：让历史发生多次，并摆弄它的不同部分，以看看是什么导致了同理心的下降。但当然，你知道，你可以指出人们生活方式的巨大转变。其中之一就是我们变得越来越城市化，越来越孤独。当我们与人互动时，往往是以更具交易性的方式，对吧？曾经把我们带入与其他人接触的一些常规做法，往往正在让位于更孤独的追求。因此，有一些证据表明，例如，匿名互动并不利于
empathy. So I don't know, there's not data specifically on solitary living, but to the extent that living in a giant city but by yourself, where most of the people who you see are total strangers, there's some evidence that suggests that perhaps that might have an effect on our empathy. And of course, one of the other places where anonymity rules is the Internet. And when you look at some of the changes that have unfolded and the timetable of those changes, they do coincide at least correlationally with the rise of Internet technologies. And I'm wondering, is there reason to imagine that there's a connection between these two things, that the connections we have with one another online and on Twitter or social media,
同理心。所以我不知道，没有关于独居的具体数据，但就住在巨大城市里却独自一人而言，你看到的大多数人都是完全的陌生人，有一些证据表明，这或许可能会对我们的同理心产生影响。当然，匿名统治的另一个地方是互联网。当你审视展开的一些变化以及这些变化的时间表时，它们至少在相关性上与互联网技术的兴起相吻合。我想知道，是否有理由想象这两者之间存在某种联系，即我们在网上、在推特或社交媒体上彼此建立的联系，
where we often don't know whom we're communicating with or who's listening or who's not listening, could this in some ways be behind this decline in empathy? It certainly is possible. You know, I think that the Internet and social media, I don't think of them as inherently antisocial. In a way, you can think of the Internet as humanity's greatest empathic opportunity ever.
在这些地方，我们通常不知道我们在和谁交流，或者谁在听，或者谁没在听，这在某种程度上可能是同理心下降的幕后推手吗？这当然是有可能的。你知道，我认为互联网和社交媒体，我不认为它们本质上是反社会的。在某种程度上，你可以将互联网视为人类有史以来最伟大的同理心机遇。
We have the chance to connect with people around the world at any time on their own terms and respond with compassion. I mean, I think if you go back and read Wired, you know, 10 or 15 years ago, people were waxing poetic about the way that the Internet could bring us all together into a global community. I think in some obvious ways that hasn't always occurred. And I think that has to do in part with some of the ways that we tend to use the Internet that might not be empathy positive.
我们有机会随时以他们自己的条件与世界各地的人们建立联系，并以同情心做出回应。我的意思是，如果你回过头去阅读《连线》杂志，你知道，在10或15年前，人们还在诗意地赞美互联网将我们所有人聚集到一个全球社区的方式。我认为在一些显而易见的方式上，这并不总是发生。我认为这在某种程度上与我们倾向于使用互联网的一些方式有关，这些方式可能对同理心没有积极作用。
So, for instance, oftentimes online, we don't. have a chance to see each other's faces and voices in sort of real-time interactions, the kind of richness that we have when we hang out offline. Instead, we see avatars and strings of text, and those might not be great triggers for empathy. There's a great study by Juliana Schroeder and her colleagues where they had people describe their political opinions sort of in an audio recording. They then had a separate group of people listen to those audio recordings or read a transcript of them. And what they found was that people were more likely to dehumanize the person whose opinion they were reading about if they were only reading it, whereas if they were hearing
所以，例如，通常在网上，我们没有。有机会在某种实时互动中看到彼此的脸和声音，就像我们在离线闲逛时拥有的那种丰富性。相反，我们看到的是头像和一串串文字，这些可能不是同理心的好触发器。朱莉安娜·施罗德（Juliana Schroeder）和她的同事有一项很棒的研究，他们让人们用录音的方式描述他们的政治观点。然后，他们让另一组人听这些录音或阅读它们的文字记录。他们发现，如果人们只是阅读别人的观点，他们更有可能将他们正在阅读其观点的人非人化；而如果他们听到
the person's voice, they were less likely to dehumanize that individual. So it's almost as though we're leaving behind when we go online some of the cues that allow us to detect each other's real humanity. And there's a deep irony there, isn't there, Jimmy? I mean, when we live in these big cities, we're living cheek by jowl with lots of other people, but in some ways we're not connecting with them, and the same goes with the Internet.
这个人的声音，他们就不太可能将该个人非人化。所以这就好像我们在上网时抛弃了一些让我们能够察觉彼此真正人性的线索。这里面有一个深刻的讽刺，不是吗，吉姆？我的意思是，当我们生活在这些大城市里时，我们与许多其他人紧密相连，但在某种程度上我们没有与他们建立联系，互联网也是如此。
We have the capacity to connect with large numbers of other people, but we're connecting in often the superficial way instead of this deeper way. It is ironic, isn't it? I mean, we, in cities, for instance, we see more people than we ever did in human history, but we know fewer of them. and it almost as though our interactions sort of favor a dehumanized perspective on each other.
我们有能力与大量其他人建立联系，但我们往往以肤浅的方式建立联系，而不是以这种更深刻的方式。这很讽刺，不是吗？我的意思是，我们在城市里，例如，我们看到的比人类历史上任何时候都多，但我们认识的却更少了。这就好像我们的互动在某种程度上偏爱了对彼此非人化的视角。
I mean, I know what I'm sort of stuck in traffic or trying to make my way down a crowded block in Manhattan. People become, not people, but obstacles for me on my way. And I think that that's sort of the way that it can often feel in modern contexts. When we come back, more on the signs of empathy and why being empathetic can sometimes be bad for you. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Jamil Zaki is the author of The War for Kindness, Building Empathy in a Fractured World.
我的意思是，我知道当我被困在交通中或者试图挤过曼哈顿拥挤的街区时。人们不再是人，而是成了我路上的障碍。我认为这正是现代语境中常常让人感觉到的方式。当我们回来时，将探讨更多关于同理心的迹象，以及为什么富有同理心有时会对你不利。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。贾米尔·扎基是《善良的战争：在一个四分五裂的世界中建立同理心》一书的作者。
He conducts research on empathy at Stanford University. Jamil, people who have been through terrible suffering can respond in different ways. Some people turn inward to avoid future pain, while others turn outward. They show empathy for the suffering of other people. I feel like I've seen research studies that show both these things. Can you talk about these studies and why people might go in one direction or another after they experienced trauma? Yeah, you know, I think that we often think of trauma, you know, sort of things like being through a war or being assaulted or suffering a terrible injury as things that, again, as you put it nicely, sort of draw us into each other. Or even that trauma might perpetuate itself.
他在斯坦福大学进行同理心研究。贾米尔，经历过可怕痛苦的人可以做出不同的反应。有些人向内转以避免未来的痛苦，而另一些人则向外转。他们对其他人的痛苦表现出同理心。我觉得我看到的很多研究表明了这两种情况。你能谈谈这些研究吗？为什么人们在经历创伤后会走向某个方向？是的，你知道，我们经常认为创伤，比如经历战争、遭到袭击或遭受可怕的伤害，正如你精彩地表达的那样，会把我们拉向彼此。甚至创伤可能会自我延续。
we often hear about cycles of violence or the idea that hurt people, hurt people. And that's certainly true in some cases. But there is a lot of research that's actually much more hopeful on what psychologists call altruism born of suffering. This is the idea that sometimes when we've gone through great pain, that actually sort of opens us up to caring more about other people and their suffering. So there are all sorts of examples of that as well. So, for instance, people who have suffered from addiction often change their lives and become addiction counselors. People who have been assaulted often change their lives and become assault counselors, sort of because they resonate with the frequency of other people suffering more acutely.
我们经常听到关于暴力循环的观点，或者受伤的人会伤害别人的想法。在某些情况下这当然是真的。但有大量研究其实更有希望，心理学家称之为“苦难中诞生的利他主义”。这个想法是，有时当我们经历了巨大的痛苦时，这实际上会让我们更加开放地关心其他人以及他们的痛苦。所以也有各种各样的例子。例如，从瘾症中痛苦过来的人经常改变他们的生活，成为瘾症辅导员。遭受袭击的人经常改变生活并成为袭击受害者辅导员，这某种程度上是因为他们对其他人痛苦的频率产生了更敏锐的共鸣。
Psychologists don't really know that much about sort of what causes people when they experience suffering to go in one direction or another. But one important factor that they have identified is the subconscious. that we receive from other people. So if after a trauma, an individual is able to find a community of others who support them, well, then they're more likely to recover from their own trauma, and they might also be more likely to turn around and provide that support to others. I'm thinking about research that Michael Wall and Naila Branscombe and others have done, looking at how when you remind people of past traumas, you remind Americans, for example, of the 9-11 attacks, Americans become more willing
心理学家其实并不太了解当人们经历痛苦时是什么导致他们走向这个或那个方向。但他们确定的一个重要因素是潜意识。我们从其他人那里得到的。因此，如果在创伤之后，个人能够找到一个支持他们的其他人社区，那么他们更有可能从自己的创伤中恢复过来，他们也可能更有可能回过头来向其他人提供这种支持。我在想迈克尔·沃尔（Michael Wall）和娜ila·布兰斯孔布（Naila Branscombe）等人所做的研究，他们研究了当你提醒人们过去的创伤时，例如提醒美国人9·11袭击，美国人变得更愿意
to endorse or tolerate harsh interrogation techniques in the fight against terrorism. And in some ways, at one level, this seems very intuitive, that you feel like you've been through something bad, and I remind you of the bad thing you've been through. And there's a part of you that says, I don't want that bad thing to happen again, and that increases my willingness to permit actions or behaviors that I might otherwise say, hang on a second, this is going to cause harm to other people. Yeah, absolutely. And I mean, I think that it cuts both ways, right? I mean, I think reminding people of collective trauma, for instance, can make them more weary of outsiders and sort of more, as you say, willing to even endorse violence or aggression towards outsiders. But thinking of a common threat is also one way to bring people within a group closer together. I remember after 9-11 the way that a Americans really felt like we were all one because we were facing this really deep trauma together.
在反恐斗争中支持或容忍严厉的审讯技术。在某些方面，在一个层面上，这似乎非常直观，你觉得自己经历了一些糟糕的事情，而我提醒你你经历过的糟糕的事情。你内心有一部分会说，我不想让那种糟糕的事情再次发生，这增加了我允许某些行动或行为的意愿，否则我可能会说，等一下，这会对其他人造成伤害。是的，绝对的。我的意思是，我认为这具有双面性，对吧？我的意思是，提醒人们集体创伤，例如，会让他们对局外人更加警惕，而且正如你所说，更愿意甚至纵容针对局外人的暴力或侵略。但思考共同的威胁也是使群体内的人们更紧密结合在一起的一种方法。我记得在9·11之后，美国人真的觉得我们都是一体的，因为我们正共同面对这个非常深重的创伤。
And likewise, there's all sorts of evidence that when people feel that they have a common threat that they're facing, they ban together. So it's really interesting. What you're really pointing out is that empathy in some ways has this double-edged sword quality to it, which is on the one hand it's prompting us to be outward looking, but it's also driven in some ways by factors about who's in our in group and who's not in our in group. The psychologist Paul Bloom, who wrote the book against empathy, the case for rational compassion, he argues that empathy tends to be parochial and it tends to be biased.
同样，有各种各样的证据表明，当人们感到他们面临共同的威胁时，他们会团结在一起。所以这真的很有趣。你真正指出的是，同理心在某种程度上具有这种双刃剑的性质，一方面它促使我们向外看，但另一方面它在某种程度上也是由关于谁是我们的内群体、谁不是我们的内群体的因素驱动的。心理学家保罗·布鲁姆（Paul Bloom）写了《反同理心：理性同情之案》一书，他认为同理心往往是狭隘的，而且往往带有偏见。
And that's why when we ask people to be empathic, we're really inviting them to be prejudiced. Is that true? I think that Paul is right in certain ways. Absolutely, empathy sort of begins parochially. Our instinctive empathy might be more driven towards people in our tribe than outside of it. I often think of oxytocin, you know, this chemical that sort of causes us to bond to other people, right? We often think of oxytocin as the love drug or the cuddle hormone. But it turns out that if you give people oxytocin intranasally, for instance,
这就是为什么当我们要求人们有同理心时，我们实际上是在邀请他们带有偏见。是真的吗？我认为保罗在某些方面是正确的。绝对的，同理心在某种程度上是以狭隘的方式开始的。我们本能的同理心可能更多地被驱动向我们的部落内部的人，而不是部落外部的人。我经常想到催产素，你知道，这种化学物质会促使我们与他人建立联系，对吧？我们经常把催产素称为爱的情药或拥抱荷尔蒙。但事实证明，如果你给人们鼻腔内注射催产素，例如，
they become more caring about people in their group, but less caring about people outside their group. since sort of turning up people's empathy in that case means turning up their parochialism. I think a big place where Paul and I differ is on what we do with this information. So Paul, I think, believes that, okay, empathy tends to be parochial and biased towards insiders versus outsiders, so we should give up on it all together. I think differently. I think that that's a problem with how empathy tends to operate, but I try to focus us on the fact that we can control how we empathize and make choices about the way that we deploy
他们会更关心群体内部的人，而对群体外部的人不那么关心。因此，在这种情况下，开启人们的同理心意味着开启他们的狭隘性。我认为保罗和我存在巨大分歧的一个地方在于我们如何处理这些信息。所以保罗，我认为，相信，好吧，同理心往往是狭隘的，并且对内部人士与外部人士有偏见，所以我们应该完全放弃它。我有不同的看法。我认为那是同理心运作方式的一个问题，但我试图让我们专注于这样一个事实：我们可以控制我们如何去同理，并对我们如何部署
our caring. And if we recognize that, hey, I'm empathizing in a parochial way, in a tribal way, we can try to make a different choice and broaden our empathy even towards people who are different from ourselves. You've done some very interesting work with police officers where you brought to bear this insight that you just talked about. Tell me about that work and tell me about how sometimes the right recommendation might actually be to tell people behave a little less sympathetically. Yeah. So for the book, I profiled Washington State's Criminal Justice Training Center. Although these officers were very empathic towards citizens, they were even more empathic towards fellow police officers, and that included fellow police officers who had engaged in potential
我们的关怀做出选择。如果我们意识到，嘿，我正以一种狭隘的方式、部落化的方式去同理，我们可以尝试做出不同的选择，并拓宽我们的同理心，甚至延伸到与我们不同的人身上。你对警察做了一些非常有趣的工作，你在其中运用了你刚刚谈到的这种见解。跟我讲讲那项工作，并告诉我有时正确的建议实际上可能是告诉人们表现得稍微不那么富有同情心一点。是的。为了这本书，我剖析了华盛顿州的刑事司法培训中心。尽管这些警官对公民非常有同理心，但他们对同僚警察更有同理心，这包括那些参与了潜在的
police misconduct, right? So while I was there, there was a case. of police officers who had shot an unarmed man named Antonio Zambrano Montes. And during my visit to CJTC, the officers involved in that shooting, they're not indicted at all. So that seemed like a travesty of justice to many people in Washington State, but the people at CJTC were adamant that these were good guys who had just made a mistake. that level of empathy for people in their own group, I feel, and this is just my perspective, might have interfered with their ability to understand how the rest of the world saw what had happened. And in fact, this is consistent with research by my friend Emil Bruno.
警察不当行为的同僚警察，对吧？所以当我在那里时，有一个案例。警察枪杀了一名名叫安东尼奥·赞布拉诺·蒙特斯（Antonio Zambrano Montes）的未武装男子。在我访问CJTC期间，参与那次枪击事件的警官根本没有被起诉。所以对于华盛顿州的许多人来说，这似乎是对正义的嘲弄，但CJTC的人坚持认为这些人是好人，只是犯了一个错误。这种对他们自己群体中人的同理心水平，我觉得，这只是我的观点，可能会干扰他们理解世界上其他人如何看待所发生事情的能力。事实上，这与我的朋友埃米尔·布鲁诺（Emil Bruno）的研究是一致的。
He's studied sort of parochial empathy in a lot of different intergroup contexts. And what he finds is that sometimes if you want to predict when someone will be, willing to be aggressive towards outsiders or unwilling to compromise with someone on the other side of a conflict. It's not enough to measure whether they empathize with the people on the outside. You have to also measure how empathic they are to their own group. And it turns out that people who are extraordinarily empathic towards people in their group, even if they're also empathic towards outsiders, are unwilling to compromise, unwilling to do anything that could threaten their own tribe. So what this suggests is that sometimes if we want to open ourselves up to other cultures,
他在许多不同的群际背景下研究了狭隘的同理心。他发现，有时如果你想预测某人何时会愿意对局外人表现出攻击性，或者不愿意在冲突的另一方妥协。仅仅衡量他们是否对外面的人有同理心是不够的。你还必须衡量他们对自己群体有多富有同理心。事实证明，那些对本群体的人极其富有同理心的人，即使他们对局外人也富有同理心，也不愿意妥协，不愿意做任何可能威胁到他们自己的部落的事情。所以这表明，有时如果我们想对自己敞开心扉去接纳其他文化，
to people on the other side of a political or racial divide, maybe what we should start out doing is not just trying to get to know them and empathize more with them, but to recognize if we're empathizing so much with our group that we'll be unable to be flexible emotionally. I want to talk about another paradox of empathy. You say that about 50% of people, you say that about 50% of oncologists report feeling intense heartbreak when they communicate bad news to patients. So even as empathy is, this very powerful driver of positive outcomes in medical settings, for example, it also seems to come at some personal cost. Yeah, in fact, even having medical students simulate delivering bad news makes them anxious,
去接纳政治或种族鸿沟另一边的人，也许我们应该做的事情不仅仅是试图了解他们并对他们有更多同理心，而是要认识到我们是否对自己的群体有太多的同理心，以至于我们在情感上无法保持灵活性。我想谈谈同理心的另一个悖论。你说大约50%的人，你说大约50%的肿瘤科医生报告说，在向患者传达坏消息时，他们会感到强烈的悲伤。因此，尽管同理心在医疗环境中是非常强大的积极结果的驱动力，例如，它似乎也带来了一些个人成本。是的，事实上，即使让医学生模拟传递坏消息也会让他们感到焦虑，
makes their palms start to sweat and their heart start to race. Empathy is hugely beneficial, including in medical contexts, for the people who receive. receive it. But it can be an occupational hazard for the people who give it. I understand that a friend of yours is a psychotherapist and she avoids scheduling depressed patients at the end of the day for in some ways the same reason. Yeah, yeah, because she feels as though their negative mood will seep into her and sort of leave her unable to interact well with her family. And I think this is part of the double-edged sword of empathy for people in caring profession. On the one hand, many of these people are driven to their work by a preternatural care for others.
让他们的手掌开始出汗，心跳开始加速。同理心非常有用，包括在医疗环境中，对于接受它的人来说。但对于付出它的人来说，这可能是一种职业危害。据我了解，你的一个朋友是一名心理治疗师，她避免在一天结束时安排抑郁症患者，在某种程度上也是出于同样的原因。是的，是的，因为她觉得他们的负面情绪会渗入她体内，让她无法与家人进行良好的互动。我认为这是照顾职业中同理心双刃剑的一部分。一方面，这些人中的许多人由于对他人超乎寻常的关怀而被驱使从事他们的工作；
But on the other hand, that same care can cause them to lose themselves, especially if they're in really intense medical settings where they're surrounded by, sort of chronically surrounded by other people's deep suffering. And as a result, oftentimes I think people in caring professions feel like they're stuck in a double bind between caring for other people adequately, but potentially grinding themselves down or turning themselves off. This is something that is called in the medical profession
但另一方面，同样的关怀也会导致他们迷失自我，特别是如果他们身处非常紧张的医疗环境中，周围是、可以说是长期被其他人深重的痛苦所包围。因此，结果是，我认为照顾行业中的人们经常觉得他们陷入了一种两难境地：既要充分照顾他人，但又有可能把自己磨垮或关闭自我。这是医疗行业中被称为的一种现象
defensive dehumanization. The idea that physicians and other healthcare professionals feel like they sometimes have to turn off their empathy and stop seeing their patients as people just so they can go on being people. You cite this interesting study that Mark Penzer conducted in a number. in the 1970s, which is another example of this kind of defensive behavior where people avoid
防御性去人性化。这种想法是，医生和其他医疗保健专业人员觉得他们有时不得不关闭同理心，停止将患者视为人，这样他们才能继续做人。你引述了马克·彭泽（Mark Panser）在一些地方进行的一项有趣的研究。在20世纪70年代，这是这种防御行为的另一种情况，人们避免
situations where they might be called upon to demonstrate empathy. What was the study and what did he find? Yeah, this was a fascinating study where Panser placed a table sort of asking for charitable donations and the table had a request for donations to charity. Sometimes the table had no one manning it and sometimes the table had a person there who was in a wheelchair. And what he found is that when he put those empathic triggers on the table, people actually walked further away. They sort of went out of their way to avoid the table more. It was almost as though they were trying to keep physical distance between them
那些可能需要他们表现出同理心情境。那项研究是什么，他发现了什么？是的，这是一项引人入胜的研究，彭泽摆放了一张桌子，上面写着呼吁慈善捐款的要求，桌子上有一个向慈善机构捐款的请求。有时桌子旁边没有人看守，有时桌子旁坐着一个坐轮椅的人。他发现，当他把这些同理心的触发器放在桌子上时，人们实际上走得更远了。他们会特意绕道避开这张桌子。这就好像他们试图在自己和某些会让他们感到同理心的事物之间保持身体距离，
and something that would make them feel empathy, either because it would feel bad or because it would force them to do something like donate that maybe they didn't really want to do. I think a lot of us have this experience when we see, for instance, a homeless individual on the sidewalk ahead of us. I've heard of people who cross the street to avoid that encounter, maybe because they don't want to sort of see that person suffering close up because it will make them feel sad or guilty or both.
无论是因为感觉不好，还是因为它会迫使他们做一些诸如捐款之类的事情，而这或许并不是他们真正想做的。我想我们很多人在看到例如人行道前方有一个无家可归的人时，都有过这种经历。我听说过有人为了避开那种遭遇而过马路，也许是因为他们不想近距离看到那个人的痛苦，因为那会让他们感到悲伤或内疚，或者两者兼而有之。
There's some irony there, isn't there, which is that the person who is likely to actually be more empathic is also the person who's likely to cross the street because they recognize that the empathy that they have inside them is going to make them feel bad. Absolutely. Yeah, I've talked with lots of people who identify as empaths and basically say that they're crippled by their overabundance of care for other people and that sometimes they avoid sort of busy cities overall just because they don't want to be inundated with other people's pain. So in other words, empathy not only can produce pain, pain can not only produce disengagement, but we can actually almost dehumanize other people because we're so, in some,
这里面有一定的讽刺意味，不是吗？也就是说，那个实际上可能更有同理心的人，也很有可能是那个过马路的人，因为他们认识到他们内心的同理心会让他们的感觉变糟。绝对的。是的，我曾和许多自认具有同理心的人交谈过，他们基本上说他们因对他人过度的关怀而感到身心疲惫，有时他们完全避开繁忙的城市，仅仅是因为不想被他人的痛苦淹没。换句话说，同理心不仅会产生痛苦，痛苦不仅会导致脱离，而且我们实际上几乎可以把其他人非人化，因为我们在某种程度上，
some ways reluctant to accept the pain that comes with actually empathizing with him. Yeah, absolutely, especially if you or a group that you belong to is responsible for that pain, because then empathy can twist into a sense of guilt or even self-loathing. And there's a dramatic example of this that was studied about 10 years ago with death workers in the American South. These are executioners. And what they found is that people who worked on death rose were likely to dehumanize inmates and say that they had given up the right
某种程度上不愿接受伴随同理心而来的痛苦。是的，绝对的，特别是如果你或你所属的群体对那种痛苦负有责任时，因为那样同理心就会扭曲为一种内疚感甚至是自我厌恶。大约10年前，对美国南部的死囚执行人员进行的一项研究中有一个引人注目的例子。这些是行刑人员。他们发现，在死囚牢房工作的人更有可能将犯人非人化，并说他们已经放弃了被当作人对待的权利。
to be treated like people. And this was especially true if they were the ones physically involved in delivering lethal injections and the like. So again, in lots of ways, empathy can hurt us. It can be unpleasant or cause us to view ourselves in ways that we don't like.
特别是如果他们是亲自参与执行致命注射等任务的人。所以再次强调，在很多方面，同理心会伤害我们。它可能令人不快，或者导致我们以我们不喜欢的方式看待自己。
And that in turn can cause us to avoid it. When we come back, how to manage this tricky balance and how we can train ourselves with deliberate practice to be more empathetic. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. During his month-long performance art piece, tens of thousands of paintballs were fired at Wafa Bilal in his studio. The white walls of his gallery turned fluorescent yellow.
这反过来又会导致我们避开它。当我们回来时，将探讨如何管理这种微妙的平衡，以及我们如何通过刻意练习来训练自己变得更有同理心。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在他为期一个月的行为艺术作品中，成千上万枚漆弹向瓦法·比拉尔在工作室里发射。他画廊的白墙变成了荧光黄色。
that you could just keep repeating getting hit. On day 11, a shooter from Estonia began bombarding his lamp until it fell apart. It was sad for me because the lamp represented just the only thing that stay alive beside me in the space, especially at night. Viewers online could see Wafa's sadness. Later that day, one of those viewers came to visit him in person.
你可以一直重复挨打。在第11天，来自爱沙尼亚的一名射手开始轰炸他的台灯，直到它散架。这让我很难过，因为台灯代表了除了我之外在这个空间里唯一能活下来的东西，尤其是在晚上。网上的观众可以看到瓦法的悲伤。那天晚些时候，其中一位观众亲自来看望他。
The lamp was totally broken. I have a person here walked in with a brand a new lamp. Hi, my name is Matt. I was watching the camera this morning. I saw the lamp went out. So I had some time I thought I'd run to target. Got a new lamp and some light bulbs. So I know sometimes you need all the help you can get even in a situation like this.
灯完全坏了。我这里有一个人拿着一个全新的灯走进来。嗨，我叫马特。我今天早上一直在看摄像头。我看到灯熄灭了。所以我有一些时间，我想我应该跑去塔吉特。买了一个新灯和一些灯泡。所以我知道有时你需要你能得到的所有帮助，即使在这种情况下。
So I'd bring that by and I'll just help you out a little bit. Jamil, talk about this moment. Perfect strangers are attacking Wafa and then a perfect stranger shows up to help him. What do you think causes someone to take the step of saying, this problem is my problem, this suffering is my suffering? Well, it's a beautiful story and, you know, there's so many like it. And I think it really, Wafa's story shows you the two sides of how empathy can work in our modern context, right? On the one hand, you've got people who are anonymous sort of feeling as though, you know, they've had the break lines cut from their social lives and they can,
所以我顺便带了这个来，只是想帮点小忙。贾米尔，谈谈这个时刻。素不相识的陌生人正在攻击瓦法，然后一个素不相识的陌生人出现来帮助他。你认为是什么原因让某人迈出这一步，说这个问题是我的问题，这种痛苦是我的痛苦？嗯，这是一个美丽的故事，而且，你知道，有很多类似的故事。我认为这确实，瓦法的故事向你展示了同理心如何在我们的现代语境中发挥作用的两面性，对吧？一方面，你有一群匿名的人，感觉好像，你知道，他们的社交生活的刹车线被剪断了，他们可以，
can do whatever they want without having to worry about the consequences. So they're acting aggressively towards a total stranger. On the other hand, you have someone who taps into that stranger's story, who's paying attention to Wafi, he's watching the video of him and realizing what he's going through, sort of able to tap into the story of this stranger, and that, instead of destroying his empathy, builds it, stretches it towards this person and drives him, inspires him to help him.
可以随心所欲地做任何事，而不必担心后果。所以他们对一个完全的陌生人采取攻击性的行为。另一方面，你有一个人触及了那个陌生人的故事，他一直在关注瓦法，他看着瓦法的视频并意识到他正在经历什么，能够触及这个陌生人的故事，这并没有摧毁他的同理心，反而建立、延伸了它，向这个人伸出援手，并驱使他、激励他去帮助他。
I forgot to mention something is really important. Matt is a Marine. Matt wasn't the only visitor. Hi, I'm Laura. I live here in Chicago, so I came down to the gallery, and I made some of my famous muffins. It's actually my sister's recipe. I noticed the other night when I went to sleep,
我忘记了一件非常重要的事情。马特是一名海军陆战队员。马特并不是唯一的访客。嗨，我是劳拉。我住在芝加哥，所以我来到了画廊，我做了一些我著名的松饼。这其实是我姐姐的食谱。我注意到前天晚上我去睡觉时，
they had one black sock on and one white socks, so I brought you some socks. There were lots of people online who helped Wafers. too. Sometimes they took control of the paintball gun by repeatedly pressing down a key and pointing the gun away from Wafa. He called them his virtual human shields. Something is really amazing happening right now. I have about 36 or so people pressing the button down on the left, preventing people from panning into my direction. Here is Wafah on day 31 after stepping outside the gallery building
他们一只脚穿着黑袜子，另一只脚穿着白袜子，所以我给你带了些袜子。网上也有很多人在帮助瓦法。有时，他们通过反复按下一个键并将枪口移开瓦法来控制彩弹枪。他称他们为自己的虚拟人类护盾。现在正在发生一件非常了不起的事情。我大约有 36 左右的人在左边按下按键，阻止人们将镜头移向我。这里是瓦法在走出画廊大楼后的第 31 天
for the first time in a month. And the whole idea is reinforce my belief in humanity and human kindness. So thank you very much for keeping the hope alive. And please keep the conversation going. It may seem surprising that Wafa's month in the paintball gallery, left him feeling optimistic about humanity. But he's not alone in that optimism. Jamil Zaki also thinks there are ways we might use technology
这是一个月来的第一次。整个理念是加强我对人性和人类善良的信念。因此，非常感谢你们让希望之火延续下去。请继续保持对话。瓦法在彩弹画廊度过的一个月让他对人性感到乐观，这或许令人惊讶。但他并不是唯一一个抱有这种乐观态度的人。贾米尔·扎基（Jamil Zaki）也认为，我们或许可以通过某些方式利用技术
to form connections with people whom we previously did not see as being like ourselves. He's done work looking at how virtual reality might help people identify with others whose lives are very different from their own. What we wanted to do is use technology to bring people, not just to sort of observe the experiences of a homeless individual, but observe them from the inside.
与那些我们以前认为与我们不同的人建立联系。他曾做过一项研究，探讨虚拟 reality（虚拟现实）如何帮助人们认同那些生活与他们截然不同的人。我们想要做的是利用技术让人们不仅去观察无家可归者的经历，而是从内部去观察。
So we had a simulation where people went through a series of scenes. These are sort of virtual reality scenes of what it might be like to become homeless. So in one scene, they've been evicted from their apartment and they're trying to figure out what they can sell to make ends meet and stay in their apartment just one more month. In the second scene, they've failed to stay in their apartment and are now sort of sleeping in their car, which is then impounded.
因此我们做了一个模拟，让人们经历一系列场景。这些有点像虚拟现实场景，展示了无家可归可能是怎样的。在一个场景中，他们被公寓驱逐，正试图弄清楚可以卖掉什么来维持生计，并在公寓里再多住一个月。在第二个场景中，他们没能继续留在公寓里，现在只能睡在车里，而车随后又被扣押了。
And then in a third scene, they're on a local bus line, which, in fact, in the Bay Area, there is a bus line that homeless individuals often take to for shelter during the night. So again, this showed people in an interactive, immersive way, the process that an individual might go through when they become homeless. What we found was that this short simulation powerfully affected people's empathy for the homeless, Even a month later, people who had gone through that simulation as opposed to a control condition were less likely to dehumanize homeless individuals. And they were more supportive of policies that would produce affordable housing for people in the Bay Area,
然后第三个场景是，他们坐上当地的一条公交路线，事实上，在湾区有一条公交路线，无家可归的人经常在夜间乘坐它来寻求庇护。因此，这再次以互动、沉浸式的方式向人们展示了一个人在无家可归时可能会经历的过程。我们发现，这个简短的模拟强烈地影响了人们对无家可归者的同理心。甚至在一个月后，经历过该模拟的人与对照组相比，不那么容易将无家可归者非人化。他们更支持能够为湾区人民提供经济适用房的政策，
which is a very sort of hot button issue around here. So again, this suggests that by putting ourselves into the story of people who on the surface appear different from us, we can recognize, as you put it nicely, our common humanity with them, and that can trigger empathy in a really natural way. There are also some less high-tech ways to get people to walk in the shoes of other people. And one of the things you mentioned in the book is the idea of the theater. How does being an actor in some ways prompt you to develop the muscle of empathy? Yeah, I mean, if you think about what acting is that you really immerse yourself so deeply in the character,
这在这里是一个非常敏感的话题。所以这再次表明，通过把自己代入那些表面上看起来与我们不同的人的故事中，我们可以认识到，正如你精辟地表达的那样，我们与他们共同的人性，这可以以非常自然的方式引发同理心。还有一些不太高科技的方法，可以让人们设身处地为他人着想。你在书中提到的其中一点就是关于剧院的想法。作为一名演员，在某些方面如何促使你培养同理心肌肉？是的，我的意思是，如果你想想什么是表演，那就是你如此深沉地沉浸在角色中，
that you stop being yourself and start being them for a little while. I mean, I'd say it's more than walking a mile in their shoes. You're almost walking a mile in their skin. And as a result, there's some evidence at least that acting, in fact, bolsters people's empathy. So in a great set of studies, Talia Goldstein looked at adolescents who were in performing arts high schools and compared them, you know, at the beginning and end of the year to students who were,
以至于你不再是自己，而是在一段时间内成为了他们。我的意思是，我觉得这不仅仅是设身处地为他们着想。你几乎是在他们的皮肤里走了一英里。因此，至少有一些证据表明，表演实际上确实增强了人们的同理心。在一系列出色的研究中，塔利亚·戈德斯坦（Talia Goldstein）观察了表演艺术高中的青少年，并将他们（在学年开始和结束时）与那些
being trained in visual arts. And what she found is that sort of acting, training in acting, improved kids' empathy more than training in a different type of art, which is not to say that training in the visual arts doesn't have advantages. I'm sure it does. But sort of embodying another person in the way that actors do, almost as like, I would say, a performance-enhancing drug for empathy, if you will. In some ways, does the same go for narrative fiction?
接受视觉艺术培训的学生进行了比较。她发现，表演方面的培训比其他类型艺术的培训更能提高孩子们的同理心，这并不是说视觉艺术培训没有优势。我相信它是有的。但正如演员那样体现另一个人，几乎可以说，如果你愿意的话，就像是同理心的表现增强剂。在某些方面，叙事小说也是如此吗？
I mean, I feel like when I'm reading a great novel, you know, I, as you said a second ago, become transported. I become, you know, a woman who's living in the 19th century. And in some ways, deeply written, beautifully written narrative fiction has this ability to pull us deep into the lives of other people. Absolutely. Yeah. I mean, this is why I love fiction as well, because it really allows us to effortlessly voyage into the lives of other people and not just see them, again, from the outside, but see them from the inside. There's a fair amount of evidence now that sort of the more fiction that people read, the more empathic that they become.
我的意思是，我觉得当我正在读一本伟大的小说时，你知道，正如你刚才所说的那样，我被带走了。我变成了一个生活在 19世纪的女性。在某些方面，构思深刻、文字优美的叙事小说具有这种将我们深深拉入他人生活中的能力。绝对是的。是的，我的意思是，这也是我热爱小说的原因，因为它确实让我们能够毫不费力地走进他人的生活，不仅是从外部看到他们，还能从内部看到他们。现在有相当多的证据表明，人们读的小说越多，他们就会变得越有同理心。
So there's a number of correlational studies that show, for instance, that children who read lots of storybooks versus those who read less fiction become more empathic. And that holds for adults also. Unfortunately for me, reading nonfiction like scientific articles, not that helpful. The journal of personality and social psychology doesn't do it? It's not really the empathy gym that some of us are looking for. But there's also some experimental evidence now coming out that even small doses of fiction produce small but reliable improvements in people's empathy. And I think this is especially important because fiction is one of the most powerful ways
因此，有许多相关研究表明，例如，读大量故事书的儿童与读较少小说的儿童相比，变得更具同理心。这对于成年人来说也成立。对我和不幸的是，阅读非小说类作品，比如科学论文，并没有那么大帮助。人格与社会心理学杂志不管用吗？这并不是我们中的一些人所寻找的同理心健身房。但现在也有一些实验证据表明，即使是小剂量的小说也能对人们的同理心产生微小但可靠的改善。我认为这尤其重要，因为小说是最强大的方式之一
to connect with people who are different from us, who maybe we might not have a chance to meet otherwise. So for instance, maybe it would be hard to meet someone. who is, I don't know, a Bolivian minor, but you could probably go to a bookstore and find a novel about their experiences. And likewise, there's some evidence, for instance, that when people read novelistic, vivid accounts of the experiences of Arab Americans or people of different gender identities than themselves,
与那些与我们不同、可能我们平时没有机会遇到的人建立联系。例如，可能很难遇到一个，我不知道，玻利维亚的矿工，但你很可能会去书店找到一本关于他们经历的小说。同样，有一些证据表明，例如，当人们阅读关于亚裔美国人或与他们自身不同性别认同的人的经历的小说化、生动的叙述时，
they form greater empathy for those other groups. We've talked in different ways about how, redefining who's in the in-group can reshape our capacity for empathy. You mentioned a very interesting research study in the book involving fans of the Manchester United soccer team. Do you remember that study? And if you do, can you tell me about it? Yeah, I love this study from Mark Levine and his colleagues. So they recruited rabid Manchester United fans. And, you know, fandom in UK soccer is very important. And they asked them to write about why they loved Manchester United so much, and then told them that they would go to a different
他们对这些其他群体产生了更强的同理心。我们从不同的角度讨论了重新定义谁是内群体如何重塑我们的同理心能力。你在书中提到了一项非常有趣的研究，涉及曼彻斯特联队足球俱乐部的球迷。你还记得那项研究吗？如果记得，能跟我讲讲吗？是的，我很喜欢马克·莱文（Mark Levine）及其同事的这项研究。因此，他们招募了狂热的曼联球迷。而且，你知道，英国足球中的球迷文化非常重要。他们让他们写下为什么他们如此热爱曼联，然后告诉他们去校园里的另一座
building on campus to watch film of Man New playing. While they were on their way across campus, they came across a jogger who appeared to twist his ankle and fall to the ground, writhing in pain. This person was, in fact, an actor, and the trick here was that the psychologist made it such that sometimes that actor was wearing a Manchester United jersey. Sometimes they were wearing a jersey of Liverpool, which at the time was Manchester United's most hated rival, and other times they were wearing a blank jersey. And what they found was that Mann U fans were more than willing to help fellow Man U fans, but also more than willing to basically step over a Liverpool fan as they sort of writhed on the ground in pain.
建筑去观看曼联比赛的录像。当他们穿过校园时，他们遇到了一位慢跑者，他似乎扭伤了脚踝，痛苦地倒在地上扭动着。这个人其实是一个演员，这里的把戏是心理学家做了一些安排，有时那个演员穿着曼联的球衣。有时他们穿着利物浦的球衣，利物浦当时是曼联最痛恨的死敌，还有的时候他们穿着一件空白的球衣。他们发现曼联球迷非常愿意帮助同为曼联球迷的人，但也非常愿意直接跨过一个利物浦球迷，因为他们在地上痛苦地扭动。
This is sort of classic tribalism in terms of our empathy and generosity. But what I love about this study is that the psychologist ran a second version of it. And here, instead of asking Man U fans to write about why they loved the team, they asked them to write about why they loved soccer, why it is such a beautiful game. And then they put them in the same scenario. And what they found was that after writing about how much they loved soccer, individuals were not just willing to help fellow Man U fans, but also willing to help Liverpool fans.
这是我们在同理心和慷慨方面的典型部落主义。但我喜欢这项研究的地方在于，心理学家进行了第二版的研究。在这里，他们没有让曼联球迷写他们为什么爱这支球队，而是让他们写为什么他们热爱足球，为什么这是一项如此美妙的运动。然后他们把他们放在同样的场景中。他们发现，在写下自己有多热爱足球之后，个人不仅愿意帮助同为曼联球迷的人，也愿意帮助利物浦球迷。
they still didn't help the person in the blank jersey, which I guess suggests that it's better, which I suppose suggest that it's better to be part of any tribe than part of none. But I think there's a deeper takeaway from this study, which is that, yes, it's easier to empathize with people who are like us than unlike us. But all of us have many different selves inside us at any given moment. And each self carries with it a different group, maybe of a different size. So if I think of myself, for instance, as a Stanford person,
他们仍然没有帮助穿着空白球衣的人，我想这表明，或者说我猜这表明，成为任何一个部落的一部分总比不属于任何部落要好。但我认为这项研究有一个更深层的启示，那就是，是的，对我们来说，与像我们的人产生同理心比与不像我们的人更容易。但在任何给定的时刻，我们所有人的内心里都有许多不同的自我。每个自我都带有不同的群体，或许体量不同。所以如果我认为我自己是一个斯坦福人，
well, then people at UC Berkeley are my mortal enemy, especially during the big game. But if I think of myself as a Californian, then my in-group, the people who deserve my empathy and who it's easy to empathize with, that group grows. And if I can think of myself as, I don't know, an American or a human being, then that group will grow even further. You know, I'm thinking about the story you told me about your
那么加州大学伯克利分校的人就是我的死敌，尤其是在大比赛期间。但如果我认为自己是一个加州人，那么我的内群体，那些值得我同理心并且很容易产生同理心的人，那个群体就扩大了。如果我能认为自己是一个，我不知道，美国人或人类，那么这个群体就会进一步扩大。你知道，我想到了你告诉我关于你的
parents divorced when you were a small child. You write in the book about your parents that two people's experiences could differ so drastically, yet both be true and deep, is maybe the most important lesson I've ever learned. I think, you know, I often attribute that period of my life to really making me who I am at the deepest level. I mean, I think not for nothing, they say that research is me search, right? At least in psychology, people tend to gravitate towards ideas. is that have made an impact on their life. And I think for me, empathizing with my parents was a survival skill that I needed just to sort of keep my family together at some level.
父母在你很小的时候离婚的故事。你在书中写到关于你的父母：“两个人的经历可能如此截然不同，但却又都真实而深刻，这也许是我学到的最重要的一课。”我想，你知道，我经常把那段生活归功于它真正造就了最深处的我。我的意思是，我认为“研究就是自我研究”这话并非毫无道理，对吧？至少在心理学中，人们倾向于被那些
But it also taught me at a much broader level that people can be fundamentally different from each other for fundamentally similar reasons. Right? My parents had totally different values, not because one of them. them was wrong or because one of them was a bad person, but because of the lives that they had lived and the experiences that they had had had had hurt them and helped them along the way. I think that this is a lesson that I try to impart to all of my students as well, is that oftentimes when we encounter someone who's different from ourselves and has an opinion or
对他们的生活产生过影响的想法所吸引。我想对我来说，与我的父母产生同理心是一种生存技能，我需要它来在某种程度上维系我的家庭。但它也在更广泛的层面上教导我，人们可能出于根本上相似的原因而在根本上彼此不同。对吧？我的父母有完全不同的价值观，不是因为他们中的一个人。错了，也不是因为其中一个人是个坏人，而是因为他们所过过的生活以及他们经历过的事情在这一路上伤害了他们，也帮助了他们。我认为这也是我试图传授给我所有学生的一课，那就是通常当我们遇到一个与我们不同、有着某种观点或
viewpoint maybe that we even abhor, it's easy to just view them as being either obtuse or honest or both. But that's a mistake. It's something that psychologists call naive realism, the idea that your version of the world is the world. And I think that empathy at a deep level is the understanding that someone else's world is just as real as yours. Developing that understanding of another person's world
甚至是我们所厌恶的观点的人时，我们很容易把他们看作是愚钝、不诚实，或者两者兼有。但这是一种错误。心理学家称之为朴素现实主义，即认为你眼中的世界就是世界的全部。我认为深层次的同理心是这样一种理解：别人的世界和你的世界一样真实。培养对另一个人世界的这种理解
requires real vulnerability. We can only begin to see things through another person's eyes if they are willing to tell us who they really are. Being that open with another person can be daunting and terrifying. Recently, we talked with psychologist Leslie John about the secrets we keep and when, how, and why we choose to reveal them to others. Those episodes were titled Keeping Secrets and Coming Clean. Shortly after those episodes came out, we received a voice memo from a listener named Mung.
需要真正的脆弱性。只有当他们愿意告诉我们他们究竟是谁时，我们才能开始透过另一个人的眼睛看事物。对另一个人如此坦诚可能会令人望而生畏且感到恐惧。最近，我们与心理学家莱斯利·约翰（Leslie John）探讨了我们保守的秘密，以及我们何时、如何以及为什么选择向他人揭示这些秘密。这些剧集的标题是《保守秘密》和《坦白从宽》。这些剧集播出后不久，我们收到了一个来自听众孟（Mung）的语音备忘录。
Right around the time, I listened to the episode Keeping Secrets. I suffered a sudden hearing loss where I woke up one day and one of my years I just couldn't hear much and just didn't know what happened. Meng freaked out. She didn't know what to do. One day, her child had a play date with another child, the mother of the other child and Meng spent some time together. So when we were hanging out, she asked me, how are you doing? You know, normally you just say, I'm doing well and keep carrying the conversation. But instead, I just listened to her So I told her, I just lost my hearing on one side of my ear.
就在我收听《保守秘密》那一集的时候，我遭受了突发性听力损失，有一天我醒来，发现我的一只耳朵几乎听不见了，完全不知道发生了什么。孟吓坏了。她不知道该怎么办。有一天，她的孩子和另一个孩子有一次约玩，另一个孩子的母亲和孟花了一些时间在一起。所以当我们在一起玩的时候，她问我：“你最近怎么样？”你知道，通常你只会说：“我挺好的”，然后继续聊天。但相反，我只是听她说话，然后我告诉她：“我的一侧耳朵刚刚失聪了。”
I don't know what's causing it. I saw my primary care physician. She couldn't see anything wrong. She sent a referral to a specialist, but I need to wait for insurance clearing. But it has been going on for almost two weeks now. And my friend got really concerned. She said her partner had the same issue and he didn't go see a doctor until a month and a half later after he lost his hearing,
我不知道是什么原因引起的。我看了我的初级保健医生。她看不出有什么不对劲。她给我开了一张转诊单去见专科医生，但我需要等待保险审批。但这已经持续了将近两个星期了。我的朋友非常担心。她说她的伴侣也有过同样的问题，他在失聪一个半月后才去看医生，
and he never was able to get his hearing back because he lost a crucial window to see the doctor. So my friend urged me to go see a doctor right away. Meng listened to the advice. She drove to the emergency room where she quickly got a referral to a specialist who figured out what was wrong and what to do. Moving quickly, Meng says,
而且他再也没有恢复听力，因为他错过了看医生的关键窗口期。所以我的朋友敦促我立刻去看医生。孟听取了建议。她开车去了急诊室，在那里很快拿到了一张专科医生的转诊单，专科医生找出了问题所在以及应对方法。孟说，迅速采取行动
is the reason she got her hearing back. So I really appreciate all my friends were there to support me to get the treatment right away. If I didn't share my secret, I would probably not be able to hear on my life year anymore. So that was a really great experience. And I learned when you have people you trust,
是她恢复听力的原因。所以我真的很感谢所有支持我立刻接受治疗的朋友们。如果我没有分享我的秘密，我可能再也听不见了。所以那是一次非常棒的经历。我了解到，当你有了信任的人，
you can feel you're able to be vulnerable. You actually can have shared life experiences and benefit everyone. So that's just something I want to share with you. We all wonder how much of ourselves to share with others. Often, in social situations like the one Mung was in, we make small talk. Oh, the weather is awful right now. Did you see the game last night?
你会觉得能够展露脆弱。你实际上可以分享生活经历并让每个人都受益。所以这只是我想和大家分享的一些事情。我们都在想自己有多少应该与他人分享。通常，在孟所处的那种社交场合中，我们会进行闲聊。“哦，现在的天气真糟糕。你看了昨晚的比赛吗？”
But Mung discovered that sharing her worry helped get her the help she needed. She also made a deep connection with a friend. When we come back, Hidden Brain listeners share their stories and questions about revealing their inner cells. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. them. In last week's segment of your questions answered, we talked with psychologist Leslie John
但孟发现，分享她的担忧有助于获得她需要的帮助。她还与一位朋友建立了深厚的联系。当我们回来时，“隐藏的大脑”听众将分享他们关于展现内心的故事和问题。您正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在上一周的“回答你的问题”环节中，我们与心理学家莱斯利·约翰探讨了
about the costs of keeping secrets and the pain we feel when others keep secrets from us. Leslie is the author of Revealing the Underrated Power of Oversharing. Today, she joins us for listeners' questions and stories about what happens when we let another person in and unburden ourselves of our secrets. Leslie John, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. Leslie, we talked before about how our impulse in many interactions is to stay at a surface level, even when we want to go deeper. What does the research say are the benefits of opening ourselves to others? Oh, there's so many benefits. The core benefit is trust. When we open up to others, when we share something a bit sensitive and personal, we are actually modeling that we trust
保守秘密的代价，以及当别人对我们保守秘密时我们感到的痛苦。莱斯利是《揭秘过度分享的低估力量》（Revealing the Underrated Power of Oversharing）一书的作者。今天，她加入我们，解答听众的问题，并分享关于当我们让另一个人走进并卸下秘密包袱时会发生什么的故事。莱斯利·约翰，欢迎回到“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢邀请我来。莱斯利，我们之前讨论过，在许多互动中，我们的冲动是停留在表面水平，即使我们想要更深入。研究表明，向他人敞开心扉有什么好处？哦，有太多好处了。核心好处是信任。当我们向他人敞开心扉，当我们分享一些比较敏感和个人的事情时，我们实际上是在示范我们信任
the person. We're implicitly saying, I'm just, I'm just, telling you this because I trust you to not make a fool out of me. And so that in turn is so powerful it makes them trust us. And trust is really the kernel of all social relationships, right, which are so important for human flourishing. There are mental and physical well-being benefits to revealing, revealing wisely and opening up a little bit more makes us feel closer to our spouses, to our friends. It makes us feel known for who we really are. The research I've done in the work has really surprised me because we've also found that leaders, when they're a little vulnerable, when they share some of their weaknesses, for example, that makes their teammates and their employees
这个人。我们在含蓄地表达：“我，我只是把这告诉你，是因为我相信你不会把我当傻子耍。”因此，这反过来又如此强大，以至于让他们信任我们。信任确实是所有人际关系的核心，对吧，而人际关系对于人类的繁荣至关重要。坦白有心理和身体健康的益处，明智地坦白并多敞开心扉一点，会让我们觉得与配偶、朋友更亲近。它让我们觉得真实的自我被认可。我在这项工作中做的研究真的让我很惊讶，因为我们还发现，领导者当他们表现出一点脆弱、例如分享他们的一些弱点时，这会使他们的队友和员工
trust them more and be more motivated to work for them. We often hear the term too much information or TMI when we overshare. You have a term called TLI. What is TLI? Yeah, it's too little information. I mean, we're culturally obsessed with TMI, with oversharing. And yes, TMI is a thing. But, oh, we've paid so little attention to TLI, too little information. And the more I study and experience it, the more I think TLI is probably a bigger problem than TMI. One of the benefits of sharing a secret is what you call reciprocity. We received a note about that from a listener named Wynn. I discovered after my mother died that I have a half brother that she never told anybody about. And when I tell people that, I usually get a disclosure of a
更加信任他们，并且更有动力为他们工作。当我们分享过多时，我们经常听到“信息过载”或 TMI 这个词。你有一个词叫 TLI。什么是 TLI？是的，那是信息不足。我的意思是，我们在文化上痴迷于 TMI，也就是分享过多。是的，TMI 确实存在。但是，哦，我们对 TLI（信息不足）的关注太少了。我研究和经历的越多，我就越觉得 TLI 可能比 TMI 是一个更大的问题。分享秘密的好处之一就是你所说的互惠。我们收到了一个名叫温的听众发来的关于这方面的便条。我母亲去世后，我发现我有一个同母异父的兄弟，她从来没跟任何人提起过。当我把这件事告诉别人时，我通常会得到
similarly significant family secret from the person I'm talking to. And in fact, I was at dinner party once when I made the disclosure and everyone else at the party at the table had some similar family secret like that. So there is a lot of reciprocity associated with the disclosure of secrets. Talk about this idea, Leslie. Why is it that when we reveal our secrets to others, it becomes easier for them to reveal their secrets to us. Yeah, reciprocity comes so naturally to us. I mean, I might even say it's an instinct. So when we make ourselves vulnerable by sharing something sensitive, we're showing that we trust the person. We're communicating that we're safe because we just put ourselves out on the line.
来自我交谈的人的类似重大家庭秘密的透露。事实上，我有一次去参加晚宴时透露了这件事，派对上桌子上的每个人都有类似这样的家庭秘密。因此，与秘密的透露相关的互惠有很多。谈谈这个想法，莱斯利。为什么当我们向他人透露我们的秘密时，他们就会更容易向我们透露他们的秘密。是的，互惠对我们来说太自然了。我的意思是，我甚至可以说这是一种本能。因此，当我们通过分享一些敏感的事情让自己变得脆弱时，我们是在表明我们信任这个人。我们正在传达我们是安全的，因为我们刚刚把自己置于风口浪尖上。
And that prompts people to reciprocate that. It's also a gesture, a gesture of, it's a kind gesture, right, to say you trust someone in that way. And it prompts them to engage, because also fundamentally opening up is something that does feel good to the right people in the right place. In one study, Leslie, you found a hurting effect in revealing secrets. Describe the study and what you found. Yeah, so what we did in this study was we asked people a bunch of questions that varied in how sensitive they were. Like, have you ever eaten meat, poultry or fish? That's like a softball question. That when all the way up to like, have you ever had sex with a friend's spouse? So like way the whole range. And what we found was that this hurting effect whereby if you know that other people have
这促使人们进行回馈。这也是一种姿态，一种姿态，是一种友好的姿态，对吧，以这种方式说你信任某人。这促使他们参与进来，因为从根本上说，敞开心扉对于在正确的时间、正确的地点的正确人群来说确实感觉很好。在一项研究中，莱斯利，你发现在透露秘密时存在一种聚集群效应。描述一下这项研究以及你的发现。是的，所以我们在这项研究中所做的是，我们问了人们一系列敏感程度不同的问题。比如，你吃过肉类、家禽或鱼吗？这就像是一个非常简单的问题。一直到比如，你曾经和朋友的配偶发生过性关系吗？可以说是涵盖了整个范围。我们发现，这种聚集群效应意味着，如果你知道其他人已经
admitted to something or revealed something, it makes you more comfortable revealing back. And the interesting thing about this study is that it wasn't a face-to-face conversation where you may feel kind of socially compelled. Rather, it was this bare-bones online service. where we just asked people questions and we told them how other people had ostensibly answered the questions. And basically, when we told them that many people had admitted to calling in sick when they weren't sick, for example, people were more likely themselves to admit that relative to another version where we, you know, we said, almost nobody is ever calling in sick when not sick. So it's easier to reveal when you know that you're not alone. The need for reciprocity in sharing with others can sometimes backfire on us. We've all been in situations where we reveal something vulnerable about ourselves
承认了某事或透露了某事，这会让你更舒服地回馈透露。这项研究有趣的地方在于，它不是面对面的谈话，在面对面的谈话中你可能会感到某种社交上的强迫。相反，它是一个非常基础的在线服务，我们只是问人们问题，并告诉他们其他人表面上是如何回答这些问题的。基本上，当我们告诉他们很多人承认在没有生病时谎称生病请假时，例如，与另一个版本相比，人们自己更有可能承认这一点，在另一个版本中，你知道，我们说，几乎从来没有人会在没生病时谎称生病请假。因此，当你发现自己并不孤单时，透露秘密会更容易。与他人分享时对互惠的需求有时会适得其反。我们都遇到过这样的情况：我们透露了关于自己的脆弱一面
and expect the other person to reciprocate, but for whatever reason, they don't. Here's a story along those lines from listener, Abigail. I was thinking while I listened to the episode about the cost of not reciprocating when someone is open with you, what that can do to a relationship. my son recently upset another mom's son at school by accident and they were planning to talk about it the next day with the teacher but he was really upset about the idea that his friend was mad at him and I said why don't we send him a message so I gave my son my phone and he sent a message to his friend to the mom's phone number saying I'm sorry
并期望对方做出回应，但出于某种原因，他们没有。以下是听众阿比盖尔讲述的一个相关故事。我在听关于当有人对你敞开心扉时不回馈的代价以及这会对关系造成什么影响的那期节目时，我想到了这一点。我儿子最近在学校不小心惹恼了另一个妈妈的儿子，他们原计划第二天和老师谈谈这件事，但他真的很担心他的朋友生气这个想法，我说，我们为什么不给他发个消息呢，于是我把手机给了我儿子，他给他的朋友发了一条消息，发到了那个妈妈的手机号码上，说对不起
and it was an accident and just expressing a bit of vulnerability, which was a big deal for my son. And then the mom responded later saying, oh, no worries, no big deal, and I know they're going to talk about it in school tomorrow anyway. And I felt really bad from that response, and I didn't really understand why until I was listening to the podcast. And I realized that both my son and I, I think,
这只是个意外，并表达了一点脆弱，这对我儿子来说是一件大事。然后那个妈妈后来回复说，哦，没关系，这没什么大不了的，而且我知道他们明天无论如何在学校也会谈论这件事的。我从这个回复中感到非常糟糕，我真的不明白为什么，直到我听了播客。我意识到我和我的儿子，我想，
by participating and sending this message, we're trying to reveal something vulnerable and reach out and say, I'm sorry I hurt you, and looking for something reassuring in return, like, I'm not angry with you, or I am angry with you and here's how to make it better. And with the mom giving this really non-committal response
通过参与和发送这条消息，我们试图透露一些脆弱的东西并伸出援手，说，对不起，我伤害了你，并寻找一些让人安心的回报，比如，我不生你的气，或者我很生你的气，以下是如何让事情变得更好的方法。随着这位妈妈给出了这个非常不置可否的回复
that didn't really say whether she or her, son were upset. It kind of denied us the opportunity to have the conversation, and it made me feel really distant from her. So Leslie, you called the type of situation that Abigail experienced a reciprocity fail. What is that? And how can we get better at avoiding a reciprocity fail? Yeah, so exactly. A reciprocity fail is when you feel you've put yourself out there and be vulnerable, and you kind of get shot down or you don't get a welcoming response or a reveal back. And that's what Abigail is describing here. So a few things strike me about this example.
并没有真正说明她或她的儿子是否生气。这有点剥夺了我们进行对话的机会，这让我觉得和她真的产生了距离。所以莱斯利，你把阿比盖尔经历的那种情况称为互惠失败。那是什么？我们怎样才能更好地避免互惠失败呢？是的，没错。互惠失败是指你觉得自己付出了心力并表现出脆弱，而你却遭到拒绝，或者没有得到欢迎的回应或回馈。这就是阿比盖尔在这里所描述的。所以这个例子让我注意到了几件事。
One is vulnerability over text messaging and email non-face-to-face or non-phone. I think that's really tough. That's a tough setup because it's so hard to interpret emotions when you're in a communicating virtually like that. So the number one thing is first, to set yourself up for success is to talk on the phone or in person because then your emotion translates.
一个是短信和电子邮件中的脆弱性，也就是非面对面或非电话沟通。我认为这真的很难。这是一个艰难的设置，因为当你进行这种虚拟沟通时，解读情绪是非常困难的。因此，最重要的事情首先是，为了让自己取得成功，要在电话里或亲自谈话，因为这样你的情绪才能传达过去。
The second is I think that we, this is a perfect example of how we often expect someone to react in a certain way or want them to react in a certain way. And then when they don't, we get really disappointed. Well, what might we be able to do to change that? we can actually say what we need.
第二个我认为我们，这是一个完美的例子，说明我们经常期望某人以某种方式反应，或者希望他们以某种方式反应。然后当他们没有时，我们就会非常失望。那么，我们可能会做些什么来改变这一点呢？我们实际上可以说出我们需要什么。
We can actually be proactive and say, I feel terrible about this. This is a hard thing for me to say. And I'm hoping that you can tell me how you feel after hearing this, right? You know, it also struck me, Leslie, that we are aware of our own motivations when we say something. But of course, all that someone else can hear are the words coming out of our mouths. They don't have access to all of our internal feelings. And I guess it underlines the importance of really making sure that what you say reveals and reflects your inner concerns, that you're not giving short shrift to them.
我们实际上可以积极主动地说，我对这件事感觉糟糕透顶。对我来说，这是一件很难说出口的事情。我希望你在听到这个之后能告诉我你的感受，对吧？你知道，这也让我震惊，莱斯利，当我们说某些话时，我们意识到自己的动机。但当然，别人能听到的只是从我们嘴里说出来的话。他们无法接触到我们所有的内在感受。我想这强调了真正确保你所说的话揭示并反映了你内心的关切，即你没有轻视它们的重要性。
Yes, completely. And a key part of that is sharing your feelings. I think too often we think that feelings are these la la la, foo, foo, things. But feelings are data. Feelings are informative. And feelings, when you share them, they're actually very persuasive. Why?
是的，完全如此。其中的关键部分是分享你的感受。我认为很多时候我们认为感觉是那些虚无缥缈的、无足轻重的东西。但感觉是数据。感觉是翔实的。当你分享这些感觉时，它们实际上非常有说服力。为什么？
Because it's hard to fake feelings. And you also can't really argue with things. feelings and the way you can with facts, right? Feelings aren't really subject to logic and debate the way a fact is. And it's also disarming a little bit because if you, they're non-accusational if you share how you feel as opposed to comment on someone's behavior, right? So sharing our feelings is something that I really think in most areas we would benefit by doing more of.
因为很难伪装感觉。你也不能真正像对待事实那样与感觉进行争论，对吧？感觉不像事实那样受逻辑和辩论的约束。这也是有点解除武装的作用，因为如果你分享你的感受而不是评论某人的行为，它们是非指责性的，对吧？因此，分享我们的感受是我真的认为在大多数领域我们都会通过多做一些而受益的事情。
When we come back, how our propensity to share with others depends on who we're sharing with. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. When we overshare with the wrong person, it can be embarrassing. But at Harvard University, Leslie John says not sharing anything at all could be worse. Leslie, I often find that when I'm deciding what or how much to share of myself,
当我们回来时，我们将探讨我们与他人分享的倾向如何取决于我们与谁分享。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。当我们向错误的人分享过多时，可能会很尴尬。但在哈佛大学，莱斯利·约翰表示，什么都不分享可能会更糟。莱斯利，我经常发现在我决定分享自己什么或分享多少时，
it can really depend on who I'm talking to. We received a voicemail along these lines from a listener named Jeremy. He shared that he's recovering from an addiction to pornography. As a teenager, he grew up religious, so Jeremy decided to confess his sins to his church leader. I went in there and I was so terrified. My hands were sweaty. I remember just sitting in that room and just not wanting to say the thing. And he could tell that there was something I wanted to say. And he kept just gently asking. And finally, I just, I said the thing. I said, you know, I've been looking at a lot of pornography and I cried. And he said, well, you should just stop.
这 realmente 取决于我在和谁说话。我们收到了一个名叫杰里米的听众发来的关于这方面的语音信箱。他分享说他正在从色情成瘾中恢复。作为一个青少年，他在宗教环境中长大，所以杰里米决定向他的教会领袖坦白他的罪过。我走进去，我太害怕了。我的手在出汗。我记得就坐在那个房间里，就是不想说那件事。他能看出有什么事我想说。他一直温和地问着。最后，我只是，我把那件事说了出来。我说，你知道，我一直在看很多色情片，我哭了。他说，嗯，你应该直接戒掉。
and I'm telling you I was so devastated at that response. It felt like I had taken so much courage and so much energy and strength to go in and say this thing. And his response was just stop. And I had tried everything in my power to possibly stop. And I just couldn't between hormones and just being a teenage boy, of course. Well, all that did was drive me more underground. and I became better at hiding it. So, Leslie, talk a moment about the importance of recognizing someone's courage when they tell us a secret,
我告诉你，我对那个回应感到非常崩溃。感觉我鼓起了极大的勇气、精力和力量才走进来说出这件事。而他的回应只是戒掉。我已经尽我所能地去戒掉了。但在荷尔蒙和一个十几岁的男孩的生理作用下，我就是做不到。嗯，这一切所做的只是把我逼得更加入地地下，并且我变得更擅长隐藏它了。所以，莱斯利，请花一点时间谈谈在有人告诉我们秘密时认识到某人勇气的重，
not just responding to the content of the secret. Yes, yes. We think way too much about the content and not enough about the gesture of disclosure. And when we're on the receiving end, it's hard for us to empathize with just how hard it is, especially when there's power imbalances as there was in Jeremy's example. And so I think like when someone says that, think of it as a gift and say, thank you for sharing that. Like, truly, even if it's something that you're dissatisfied with, you can recognize that this took courage. And there's actually been some really interesting studies on what can, when you're on the receiving end of someone's sensitive disclosure, what is the best way to help them?
而不仅仅是回应秘密的内容。是的，是的。我们过多地考虑了内容，而没有足够地考虑披露的姿态。当我们处于接受端时，我们很难对这种事情有多么困难产生共鸣，尤其是当存在权力不平衡时，就像杰里米的例子中那样。所以我想，当有人这样说时，把它当作一份礼物，并说，谢谢你分享。真的，即使这是让你不满意的事情，你也可以认识到这需要勇气。实际上有一些非常有趣的研究关于当你处于别人敏感披露的接受端时，什么是帮助他们的最好方法？
And again and again, the best thing to do is validation. So we often think that we should problem solve, right? Like in this example, like, what are you going to do about it? But actually less is more just like recognizing their disclosure and saying, I hear you, that must be so hard. I would feel the same way too. These are forms of validation. And that is so comforting to people.
一次又一次，最好的做法是验证。所以我们经常认为我们应该解决问题，对吧？就像在这个例子中一样，比如，你打算怎么做？但实际上少即是多，就像承认他们的披露并说，我听到了，那一定很难。我也会有同样的感受。这些都是验证的形式。这对人们来说是如此安慰。
It really reduces their momentary stress levels and helps them see things more clearly and be more clearheaded. I want to bring you to the next part of general. Jeremy's story, Leslie, as he grew into adulthood, he continued to struggle with his addiction until a partner learned about it. And finally, there came a point at which I was discovered, which is often the case for people like me, and I had no choice but to come clean. And she didn't want to hear my coming clean, but I did find a program where I had some support and people who really understood what I had gone through and how this thing works.
它确实降低了他们暂时的压力水平，并帮助他们更清晰地看清事物，头脑更清醒。我想带你进入下一部分，关于杰里米的故事，莱斯利，随着他步入成年，他继续与他的成瘾作斗争，直到一个伴侣知道了这件事。最后，终于到了我被发现的时刻，对于像我这样的人来说这通常是这样的，我别无选择，只能坦白。她不想听我坦白，但我确实找到了一个项目，在那里我得到了一些支持，还有真正理解我所经历过的事情以及这件事是如何运作的人。
And when I did that to a person who really, really understood, what I felt was freedom, understanding, comfort, love to a level that I'd never felt before, I think it gave me a real good step into not having the problem. So, Leslie, I'm struck by the contrast between Jeremy's different experiences of sharing his secret. And I'm also struck by the fact that he received the most support from other people who had been through what he went through. Have you studied the power that support groups have in helping people unburdened themselves of their secrets? It's so powerful, knowing that you have a shared reality with someone that they have been going through the same things. Because when you think about it again, this idea of like feeling known for who you really are is so soothing. And so if you've had unique experiences with addiction, it's one thing to talk to an understanding spouse, but it's also incredibly curative to talk to other people who have been through similar
当我把这件事告诉一个真正、真正理解的人时，我感受到的是前所未有的自由、理解、安慰和爱，我认为这为我真正摆脱这个问题迈出了非常好的一步。所以，莱斯利，杰里米分享秘密的不同经历之间的对比让我震惊。我也震惊于这样一个事实，即他从那些经历过他所经历事情的其他 人那里获得了最多的支持。你研究过互助小组在帮助人们从秘密中解脱出来方面所拥有的力量吗？它是如此强大，知道你与某人有着共同的现实，即他们经历过同样的事情。因为当你再次考虑时，这种因为你是谁而被真正了解的感觉是如此具有抚慰性。因此，如果你有过独特的成瘾经历，与一个理解你的配偶交谈是一回事，但与经历过类似事情的其他 人交谈也具有不可思议的治疗作用
things. After the first hidden brain we did together, a bunch of my old friends from ballet reached out to me. I trained professionally classical ballet when I was a lot younger, and they reached out to me. And this was the last time I saw them was 30 years ago. And we met last month. The four of us met together. We hadn't seen each other in 30 years. And it was unbelievably bonding and wonderful and beautiful. And we talked about some of these things that at the time, you know, we lived together in grade six and seven. We were like sisters. And we went through like it was a privilege, a total privilege to get to do this to train at this level. But it was also really hard. And, you know, these things, it made me realize that things that I hadn't really processed. that were kind of lurking, that, you know, I have dreams, nightmares every month or two. Now, I don't have them anymore so far because we were able to talk about these things that were really messed up and make sense of them. Like one of these things is when you do point work, you're standing on your toes, your feet bleed,
在我们一起做的第一个《隐藏的大脑》节目之后，我的一群芭蕾舞界的老朋友联系了我。我小的时候接受过专业的古典芭蕾训练，他们联系了我。我上一次见到他们是在30年前。我们上个月见面了。我们四个人聚在了一起。我们已经30年没见了。这令人难以置信地具有凝聚力、美妙而美好。我们谈到了其中一些事情，当时，你知道的，我们在六年级和七年级时住在一起。我们就像姐妹一样。我们经历过这一切，能够以这种水平接受训练是一种特权，绝对的特权。但这也真的很难。而且，你知道，这些事情让我意识到，有些事情我没有真正处理好，它们一直在潜伏，你知道的，我每隔一两个月就会做梦、做噩梦。现在，我再也不会做这些梦了，因为我们能够谈论这些真的很糟糕的事情并理解它们。就像其中一件事是当你做脚尖舞时，你站在脚趾上，你的脚会流血，
especially at the beginning. And we never told our teachers that our feet were bleeding. So we just, we just dance with these raw feet. And the thought of telling them did not even occur to us. because the norm, this authoritarian competitive norm, was so entrenched in us that if we revealed, we would be weak. And I just made that realization with them a couple months ago. And so it just feels so good to like process these things that you've uniquely been through. It's very, very healing. I'm also wondering if it's possible that when we share things with people who've
尤其是在刚开始的时候。我们从未告诉我们的老师我们的脚在流血。所以我们只是，我们只是带着这些生疼的脚跳舞。告诉他们的想法甚至都没有出现在我们的脑海中。因为这种规范，这种威权主义的竞争规范，在我们心中根深蒂固，如果我们透露了，我们就会显得软弱。几个月前，我和他们一起意识到了这一点。所以，处理这些你独特经历过的事情感觉太棒了。这非常非常具有治愈作用。我也在想，当我们与那些
essentially been through the same experience like you had with your friends, one of the advantages is that there is so much that can be left unsaid and unspoken because, in fact, you share all of this implicit understanding and knowledge. Oh, yeah. It's so efficient. Now I'm type A business school prep. It's efficient. But it is. I mean, you don't need to set the stage. You already know the cast of characters. You know the personalities and you just go right back. It was beautiful. We received this message from a listener named Merrill that also has to do. do with the audience for our self-disclosures? Two years ago, I was the victim of a bank fraud.
本质上经历过相同经历的人分享事情时，就像你和你的朋友一样，其中一个好处是有很多东西可以不用说出来，因为事实上，你们分享了所有这些隐含的理解和知识。哦，是的。太高效了。现在我是甲型商学院预科生。这很高效。但确实如此。我的意思是，你不需要铺垫。你已经认识演员阵容了。你知道这些个性，你马上就能回去。太美妙了。我们收到了一个名叫梅里尔的听众发来的这条消息，这也与我们自我披露的受众有关？两年前，我是银行诈骗的受害者。
Three well-trained impostors from abroad contacted me by phone over a six-week period. They hooked me in with kindness and had me believing that it was in my best interest to follow their instructions. As an elderly person, I was easy prey for them. When my checking account was depleted, I didn't know who to turn to for support. Not wanting my intelligence to be judged, I kept the secret intact. Imagining words like, how could you? Didn't you see where this was going?
在长达六周的时间里，三位训练有素的外国骗子通过电话联系了我。他们用友善的态度让我上钩，让我相信遵循他们的指示最符合我的利益。作为老年人，我很容易成为他们的牺牲品。当我的支票账户被掏空时，我不知道该向谁求助。由于不想让别人对我的智力评头论足，我把这个秘密紧紧锁在心里。脑海里浮现出这样的话：你怎么会这样？难道你没看出事情会发展到这一步吗？
Why did you listen to people you didn't know? And why didn't you call me? Kept the secret even tighter. The deputy attorney general in the state I reside in contacted me by phone to speak at a symposium about fraud. Speaking with him for one hour gave release. The conversation was safe and non-judgmental because I knew this higher-up legislator
你为什么听信陌生人的话？为什么不给我打电话？这让这个秘密藏得更深了。我居住的州的副总检察长打电话给我，邀请我在一个关于欺诈的研讨会上发言。与他交谈一个小时让我得到了解脱。这种对话是安全且不带评判色彩的，因为我知道这位高级立法者
was talking to other people in my state who were in similar circumstances. So that's a powerful story, Leslie. And I think many people can relate to Merrill's experience. You know, you sit next to somebody on a bus or a train or a park bench and you tell them things that you haven't told your closest friends. Why do you think that is? Yeah.
正在和我州其他处境相似的人交谈。所以这是一个很有分量的故事，莱斯利。而且我认为很多人都能对梅里尔的经历感同身受。你知道，你坐在公共汽车、火车或公园长椅上的某个人旁边，你会把那些连最亲密的朋友都没有说过的事情告诉他们。你认为这是为什么？是的。
It's freeing because you know you're not going to see them again. It's freeing because you don't need to worry about them judging you. And in fact, sometimes especially when we know the person, it feels very like it's very hard to reveal things. And I really feel for Merrill because that's a really hard thing. You know, it can really happen to anyone, but it would be, you'd feel so stupid and it would be very hard to talk to. And I'm really glad that she, there was a professional who was really well. trained and received those disclosures in a great way. I'm wondering how much it matters whether the people we unburdened ourselves to share the same
这是一种解脱，因为你知道你们不会再见面了。这是一种解脱，因为你不需要担心他们会评判你。事实上，有时尤其是当我们认识这个人时，会觉得很难向对方吐露心声。我真的很同情梅里尔，因为这确实是一件很难的事。你知道，这种事确实可能发生在任何人身上，但你会觉得自己太蠢了，而且很难开口。我真的很高兴她能遇到一个受过良好专业培训、并以极好的方式接受这些倾诉的人。我想知道，我们向其倾诉的对象是否与我们共享相同的
values or worldview as us. We received an email from listener Allison. She writes, Before the 2016 election, when Donald Trump's comments about women and sexual assault were coming to the surface, I spoke up about how my own experience with sexual abuse had destroyed me in an attempt to show friends how serious I felt the statement. were. I did so selectively, but I live in a very conservative community, and I had a handful of friends tell me that I needed to get over my feelings about sexual assault in order to vote for
价值观或世界观，这究竟有多重要？我们收到了听众艾莉森的一封邮件。她写道，在2016年大选之前，当唐纳德·特朗普关于女性和性侵犯的言论浮出水面时，我公开讲述了我自己遭受性虐待的经历是如何毁了我的，以此向朋友们展示我对这些言论有多么重视。我是有选择性地说的，但我生活在一个非常保守的社区里，有几个朋友告诉我，为了
the greater good. I fell into a deep depression that I haven't really pulled out of. I used to be friendly and outgoing, heavily engaged in my neighborhood, church, and PTA, but even after years of therapy, I still isolate myself. I don't know my neighbors anymore. I rarely see friends, investing in relationships, especially new ones, just feels too risky. So, Leslie, how do we still share of ourselves, our experiences, our stories, when we feel that the people we're sharing with are not on the same page as us? Yeah, that's a really important question. And I think this speaks to the importance of curating your audience.
大局，我需要放下对性侵犯的感觉去投票。我陷入了深深的抑郁，至今没有真正走出来。我以前很友好、外向，积极参与社区、教堂和家长教师协会的活动，但即使经过多年的治疗，我仍然自我封闭。我不再认识我的邻居了。我很少见朋友，投资人际关系，尤其是新的关系，感觉风险太大了。那么，莱斯利，当我们觉得倾听的对象与我们不在同一个频道时，我们该如何向他们分享自我、经历和故事呢？是的，这是一个非常重要的问题。我认为这说明了策划你的听众的重要性。
Now, you can't predict people's reactions 100%. So it's not like the revealers problem all the time. But one thing that we can try to do with these really sensitive things is instead of just kind of feeling like it's a one-shot thing, we're going to just say the thing to a bunch of people. We could try, for example, we could try first saying the words out loud privately. How does that feel? And then try saying them to someone that is really close with you. Yeah. I mean, I'm also reflecting that one of the things that Alison is.
现在，你无法百分之百预测人们的反应。所以这并不总是意味着倾诉者的错。但对于这些非常敏感的事情，我们可以尝试去做的一件事是，与其只觉得这是一次性的事情，我们要把这件事对很多人说。例如，我们可以尝试先私下大声说出这些话。感觉怎么样？然后再试着对那些与你非常亲近的人说。是的。我的意思是，我也在反思，艾莉森所做的事情之一
was doing, was she was trying to frame her disclosures in the context of, you know, a very tense political situation. And I'm wondering whether Allison might have had more success if she was in a situation where even if she was with people who disagreed with her politically, she's finding some kind of a common, you know, activity or an event that people are interested in. And then sharing her self-disclosure in that context where it's not going to be interpreted through a political lens. Yeah, totally. I mean, the context massively shapes the interpretation of the self-disclosure, for sure.
是，她试图在一个非常紧张的政治局势的背景下组织她的倾诉。我想知道，如果艾莉森身处的环境是，即使与她政见不同的人在一起，也能找到某种人们感兴趣的共同活动或事件，然后在这个与政治镜头无关的语境中分享她的自我倾诉，她会不会取得更大的成功呢？是的，完全是这样。我的意思是，语境极大地塑造了人们对自我倾诉的解释，这是肯定的。
Another thing that comes to mind is, if she was here, what I would love to ask her more about is her why, like what's her purpose, what's her motive for revealing? Because a story of mine, it's not a terrible event like what Allison experienced. But, you know, when I was first pregnant with our first little guy, I was overjoyed and in a spirit of warmth and transparency, I kind of blurted it out to our landlord. Well, that sent a series of chain reactions that basically ended with us having to move out. It was definitely a disclosure that came back to bite me.
我脑海中浮现的另一件事是，如果她在这里，我很想进一步询问她的“为什么”，比如她的目的是什么，她倾诉的动机是什么。因为我自己的一个故事，它不像艾莉森经历的那么可怕。但是，你知道，当我第一次怀上我们的第一个小家伙时，我欣喜若狂，出于一种温暖和透明的心态，我有点脱口而出地告诉了我们的房东。嗯，这引发了一系列连锁反应，基本上以我们不得不搬走而告终。这绝对是一次适得其反的倾诉。
Everything worked out in the end. But, you know, and in hindsight, I'm like, why did I do that? Well, I wanted to get coups and love. And was my landlord really the right person to do that? Absolutely not. So kind of thinking those things through your goal and whether this audience is, the right person or context. We've all heard the phrase humble bragging.
最终一切都解决了。但是，你知道，事后诸葛亮，我想：我为什么要这么做？嗯，我想要获得赞赏和爱。难道我的房东真的是做这件事的合适人选吗？绝对不是。所以，我们要思考这些事情：你的目标是什么，以及这个听众是否是合适的人选或语境。我们都听过“谦虚式炫耀”这个词。
We reveal something that looks like a flaw, but it's really designed to draw positive attention to ourselves. When we come back, how to reveal things that show us in a good light. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Leslie John is a psychologist at Harvard University. She's the author of revealing the underrated power of oversharing. Leslie, we've been talking today about self-disclosure of secrets that are often painful or embarrassing,
我们透露一个看起来像是缺点的东西，但它其实是为了吸引别人对我们的正面关注。广告回来后，我们将讨论如何展现我们光鲜亮丽的一面。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。莱斯利·约翰是哈佛大学的心理学家。她是《倾诉：过度分享的低估力量》一书的作者。莱斯利，我们今天一直在讨论通常痛苦或尴尬的秘密的自我倾诉，
but you also studied how it can be difficult to share something that we are proud of. How so? Yeah, it can be hard because you don't want to make your loved ones and friend ones feel badly. You don't want to spark envy, right? you don't want them to feel jealous. And so oftentimes then what we end up doing is we end up just like not sharing the thing. And that's also problematic. This reminds me of my colleague Oval Sazer's work where on humble bragging,
但你也研究过，分享我们引以为傲的事情为什么也会很困难。为什么会这样？是的，这可能会很困难，因为你不想让你的挚爱和朋友感到难过。你不想引发嫉妒，对吧？你不想让他们感到嫉妒。所以很多时候，我们最终的做法就是选择不说。这也是有问题的。这让我想起了我的同事奥瓦尔·萨泽关于谦虚式炫耀的工作，
where what we try to do is we try to then often couch the take the edge off the brag by couching it with a display of humility. Like, oh my gosh, I can't believe my boss asked me to lead this meeting. right? Or it's so hard when I get so many text messages from all my friends. It's really hard to respond to all that. And it's just like mega eye roll, right? And so don't humble brag. It's better to outright brag. And by that I mean say the positive thing. But there's ways of being like really thoughtful about it. Like you got to consider the timing. You don't want to tell your bestie that you got a promotion when your bestie had a really bad day in his feeling down. Another thing you can do is
在这种情况下，我们试图做的是，通常通过表现出谦逊来淡化炫耀的锋芒。比如，哦天哪，我真不敢相信我的老板让我领导这个会议，对吧？或者，当我收到所有朋友发来的那么多短信时，回复所有这些信息真是太难了。这简直让人直翻白眼，对吧？所以，不要进行谦虚式炫耀。直截了当地炫耀会更好。我的意思是，说出积极的事情。但有办法对此进行深思熟虑。比如你得考虑时机。当你的闺蜜度过了糟糕的一天、情绪低落时，你肯定不想告诉她你升职了。你可以做的另一件事是
reveal like the story of how you got there, like that you worked really hard and you've been thinking about this a long time. So it's not like, oh, hey, I got promoted. Like, I'm the best. It's so easy. So you can reveal kind of the struggle. I think we need to be very careful about the timing, the recipient, and the context. And you can see that context very dramatically in how much much self-praise or self-promotion or saying positive things about myself is acceptable. Like, if you're on LinkedIn, it's weird not to self-promote. It's weird not to say, right? So you really have to read the room. A listener named Patricia called in with a story. She's from Australia and had a new boss at one
透露你是如何走到这一步的故事，比如你付出了很多努力，而且你已经考虑了很久。所以这不像是，“哦，嘿，我升职了。就像我是最棒的，这太容易了。”所以你可以透露奋斗的过程。我认为我们需要非常小心时机、接受者和语境。你可以非常戏剧性地从语境中看到，有多少自我赞美、自我推销或说自己的好话是可以被接受的。比如，如果你在领英上，不进行自我推销才奇怪呢。不表达自己才奇怪呢，对吧？所以你真的必须看人说话。一位名叫帕特里夏的听众打来电话分享了一个故事。她来自澳大利亚，有一次换了一个新老板，
point. And she shared a story with him about how she had challenged authority and gone outside the rules in a previous job. And in many ways, it turned out really well. Patricia was working in child protective services, and she really did right by the children she was working with. And she hoped that this story would show her new boss what an exceptional employee she was going to be. Unfortunately, her boss did not see the story in the same way she did.
她和老板分享了一个故事，讲述了她在之前的工作中如何挑战权威、打破常规。在很多方面，结果都非常好。帕特里夏在儿童保护服务机构工作，她对她共事的儿童确实尽到了责任。她希望这个故事能向她的新老板展示她将成为一名多么出色的员工。不幸的是，她的老板并没有以和她一样的方式看待这个故事。
He no longer talked to me after I told him this story, no longer looked at me. I was like someone that he wanted to get rid of. and I couldn't understand why. And it's because he realized that I wasn't someone that would just easily follow anything that he told me. And he wouldn't be able to control me and he wouldn't be able to make me easily conform. So after I told him that story and realized the consequences of it, I felt nothing but dread and regret. And I thought, oh God, this is one situation where I probably shouldn't have disclosed.
在我讲了这个故事后，他再也不跟我说话了，也不再看我了。我就像一个他急于摆脱的人。而我却无法理解为什么。这是因为他意识到我不是那种会轻易服从他吩咐的人。他无法控制我，也无法让我轻易顺从。所以在讲完那个故事并意识到后果之后，我感到的只有恐惧和后悔。我想，天哪，这真是一种我可能不该倾诉的情况，
because this guy was all about having power and control over his employees. So, Leslie, talk about the role that power plays in these self-disclosure dilemmas, because it seems to me that perhaps this is especially tricky terrain where we have to be careful about when and with whom we disclose. Completely. Yeah, and the workplace is a very tricky situation because, you know, in any given day, most of us, a lot of us move up and down the status hierarchy, right? Like when I'm talking to the dean, I'm low status. When I'm talking to my MBA students, I'm higher status.
因为这家伙满脑子想的都是对员工拥有权力和控制权。所以，莱斯利，谈谈权力在这些自我倾诉的困境中扮演的角色吧，因为在我看来，这可能是一个尤其棘手的领域，我们必须小心何时以及向谁倾诉。完全是这样。是的，职场是一个非常棘手的情况，因为，你知道，在任何给定的日子里，我们大多数人、很多人都在地位等级上下流动，对吧？比如当我跟系主任说话时，我的地位很低。当我跟我的MBA学生说话时，我的地位更高。
And so that really shapes disclosure too. Like your status has a big impact on what's safe. And generally as you move higher up the status poll, it's more safe to reveal sensitive things. Patricia's example is a great example of how a well-intended disclosure can come back to bite us, at least in the short run. And since we have the benefit of perspective and not being in this situation ourselves, a couple of things struck me. One is, I know this is hard, but I wondered how much she had talked to her boss about, you know,
所以这确实也塑造了倾诉。比如你的地位对什么是安全的有着巨大的影响。通常随着你地位的提高，透露敏感的事情会更安全。帕特里夏的例子很好地说明了一个出于好意的倾诉是如何适得其反的，至少在短期内是这样。既然我们有置身事外的视角优势，没有亲历这一境况，有几件事让我印象深刻。第一，我知道这很难，但我想知道她跟她老板谈过多少关于
why he reacted the way he did. Because sometimes if you can have a meeting and ask the person about more about their reactions, you will learn things that of the perspective that completely maybe explain their reaction and is not what you were thinking. So I think we kind of underask, but I don't say that lightly because when there's big status differences, it's hard to ask someone higher status, a question like that. The other thing, again, with the benefit of being way zoomed out here is so this person didn't appreciate the efforts that she had gone to.
他为什么会有那种反应。因为有时候，如果你能开个会，问问对方关于他们反应的更多细节，你就会了解到一些完全可能解释他们反应的视角，而这并不是你想的那样。所以我觉得我们往往问得不够，但我说这话并不是轻描淡写的，因为当存在巨大的地位差距时，很难向地位更高的人问出这样的问题。另一件事，同样是以置身事外的视角来看，这个人并不欣赏她付出的努力。
And I think that should prompt a question, is this the person I want to work for? Is this the organization where my values fit? And if you do have the luxury of maybe looking elsewhere like that, that's an interesting data point to consider. So I think like a big thing that I've learned is like when your self-disclosures don't go the way you want them to sometimes, if you think of them as failures, then that's really demotivating. But try to think of them as what you learned. A lot of times you learn even more from the times when you get surprising reactions in the negative way, right? Hmm. I'd like to switch gears for a moment and talk about disclosure.
我认为这应该引发一个问题：这真的是我想为之效力的人吗？这真的是一个符合我价值观的组织吗？如果你确实有奢侈去寻找其他机会，那这是一个值得考虑有趣的数据点。所以我认为我学到重要的一点是，当你的自我倾诉没有朝着你希望的方向发展时，如果你把它们视为失败，那就太打击积极性了。但试着把它们视为你学到的东西。很多时候，当你得到负面的、令人惊讶的反应时，你能学到更多，对吧？嗯。我想暂时转换一下话题，谈谈
in romantic relationships. Many people have found that there's a topic that can be particularly difficult to discuss with their partners, and that's the topic of past relationships. Listener Janet had been seeing a boyfriend for six years when she decided it was time to have the talk.
恋爱关系中的倾诉。许多人发现，有一个话题与伴侣讨论起来可能会特别困难，那就是过去的情感经历。听众珍妮在和一个男友交往六年时，她决定是时候进行那次谈话了。
I had not shared with him that I was in a very seriously damaging relationship about 20 years ago. Police were involved. There was pretty bad. And I just felt like I, wanted to share it with him. It was something that he should know about me. So we were having a conversation about vulnerability and I said there's something I'd like to share with you and it's
我没有告诉他，大约20年前我曾陷入一段受到严重伤害的关系中。警察介入了。情况相当糟糕。我只是觉得我，想要跟他分享。这是他应该知道的关于我的事情。所以我们当时在谈论脆弱性，我说有一件事我想跟你分享，
not going to be easy for me to tell you and you may judge me but I feel like I need to tell you. So I told him the story and he sat and listened and when it was all done there was just silence. I didn't know what to do, so I just sat there. And ultimately, we ended the conversation, and he decided to get up and leave and go home. And from that point forward, our relationship changed pretty profoundly. We still see each other as friends occasionally, but that's it. So that's the story.
这对我来说不容易开口，你可能会评判我，但我感觉我必须告诉你。于是我把这个故事告诉了他，他坐在那里听着，当一切结束时，只有一片沉默。我不知道该怎么办，就坐在那里。最终，我们结束了对话，他决定起身离开回家。从那一刻起，我们的关系发生了相当深刻的变化。我们偶尔还会作为朋友见面，但仅此而已。这就是故事的经过。
So Leslie, it looks like Janet was punished for being vulnerable in disclosing something that happened to her. in the past. How should we think of these moments when we put ourselves out there and the other person has a negative or awkward reaction to our disclosure? I think it's information, right? As hard as it is, and I feel so badly for Janet, I admire her courage, and it just sucks so bad when someone doesn't even know what to do with it and leaves. That said, it is a very clear signal, right? Like, this person can't handle it. I mean, especially if I've, unless there's, like a day or a few later, he comes back. He's like, oh my gosh, I'm so sorry. Like, this was
所以，莱斯利，看起来珍妮因为表现出脆弱、倾诉了过去发生的事情而受到了惩罚。我们该如何看待这些时刻：当我们向外界敞开心扉，而对方对我们的倾诉却做出消极或尴尬的反应时？我认为这是信息，对吧？尽管这很难，而且我很同情珍妮，我钦佩她的勇气，但当一个人甚至不知道该如何面对并选择离开时，这种感觉真的是糟透了。话虽如此，这却是一个非常明确的信号，对吧？比如，这个人无法处理这件事。我的意思是，特别是如果我——除非过了一天或几天后他回来了，说：“哦天哪，我很抱歉，这太令人不知所措了，”对吧？但如果它没有伴随任何类似这种巨大的弥补行为，我知道这听起来很疯狂，但这也算是一份礼物，因为这个人向她展露了真实的自我。现在，这件事发生在六年之后，我想她说的是，这，这，这真的很难接受。这是那种自我倾诉的事情之一：在短期内往往非常艰难，但对我们的长远发展却大有裨益。嗯。听众蕾切尔提出了一个心理学上很复杂的问题：我们是否可以把倾诉和脆弱当作武器？
overwhelming, right? Like, but if it's not paired with some kind of hugely rectifying behavior like that, I know this is going to sound crazy, but it's a bit of a gift because this person revealed himself to her. Now, it happened after six years, I think, she said, which is, that's, that's, that's incredibly hard to take. It's one of those things that's just self-disclosure. It's often very hard in the short run, but so good for us in the long run. Hmm. Listener, Rachel, had a psychologically complex question. Can we ever use disclosure and vulnerability as weapons?
我很好奇想听她谈谈的一件事是，像表现出脆弱这样的一件事是否可以被用作一种操纵的形式。我想我有时见证过这种行为，人们利用自己的脆弱来拉近与人们的距离，从而掌控局面。但我只是想知道这是否是一种可能，你知道，无论是在公共领域，还是在个人或工作关系中，这种把自己置于脆弱地位以在关系动态中获得更多权力的想法。现在，蕾切尔并没有给我们具体的语境或例子，莱斯利，但你
One thing I was just curious to hear her talk about was whether something like being vulnerable could be used sort of as a form of manipulation. It's a behavior I think I've witnessed sometimes where people sort of use their vulnerability to sort of get close enough to people to kind of manage the situation. But I just wonder if that is a possibility, you know, both in the public sphere and in personal or work relationships where the idea of like putting yourself in a vulnerable position to sort of gain a little more power within like a relationship dynamic. Now, Rachel didn't actually give us a specific context or an example, Leslie, but what do you
怎么看？脆弱和倾诉真的可以被用作操纵的武器吗？绝对可以。我的意思是，这可以说是审讯入门101了，对吧？就是说一些关于你自己的、敏感的事情，从而与你试图让他人坦白的目标对象建立信任。所以这绝对在他们的诡计手册里。骗子会说他们很脆弱。
think? Can vulnerability and disclosure ever be used as? as weapons of manipulation? Absolutely. I mean, this is a kind of interrogation 101, right? Is saying something about yourself that's sensitive and that builds rapport with the person you're trying to get to confess or whatever. So that's like definitely in that trick book. Scammers, they say they're vulnerable.
他们会说：“哦，不，我父亲快要死了，”对吧？所以我们会感到非常信任他们，因为他们向我们敞开心扉，尽管客观上我们知道不该这样做，但那个手势本身有些魔力。所以脆弱绝对可以被用来对付我们，而且事实也确实如此。我们需要非常小心。当我们处于脆弱或虚弱的状态时，我们更容易受到影响。甚至我记得当我三十岁出头、感到孤独、单身并重新开始约会时，在我被套牢之前我就识破了他们。但事后回想起来，确实有几个人绝对是骗子，那是那种进展太快、过于亲密的情况。我确实看穿了，但当你太渴望某种连接成真时，
They say, oh, no, my father's dying, right? So we feel very, we trust them because they're like revealing to us, even though, you know, objectively we know we should not, there's something about that gesture. So absolutely vulnerability can be used against us and it is. And we need to be very careful. And when we are in a vulnerable or weakened state, we are more susceptible. Like even I remember when I was lonely and in my mid-30s and I found myself single and I was dating again. Like I caught them before I got looped in. But there was a couple of people that were definitely scammers in hindsight. they were, and it was the situation of like too close, too quickly. And I did see through it, but it's just when you want something to be so true with connection,
如果你在寻找爱，那正是我们非常容易让脆弱被这种方式操纵的时刻之一。我们收到了听众诺拉的一个有趣问题，关于利用自我倾诉作为减少紧张和冲突的一种方式。当我刚开始和我丈夫约会时，我见了他大学里的很多朋友，其中有一个女人，每当我试图和她说话或开玩笑时，她对我的态度总是有点奇怪。我遭遇的是冷淡或讽刺，这似乎完全没有道理。当我问我丈夫时，
if you're looking for love, like that's one of these moments when we're very susceptible to a vulnerability being manipulated by that way. We got an interesting question from listener Nora about using self-disclosure as a way to reduce tension and conflict. When I first started dating my husband, I met a lot of his college friends, and one of them was this woman who always behaved kind of strangely toward me whenever I made an attempt to talk or joke with her. I was met with this chilliness or sarcasm that really seemed unwarranted. And when I asked my husband about it,
他有点敷衍了事，向我保证这并不是因为什么嫉妒或他们过去的感情。但你可以想象，每次见到她，都是我焦虑的来源，这极大地损害了我对无论什么场合的享受。这种情况持续了好几年，直到有一天我决定邀请她来家里。我们以前从来没有单独相处过，经过几次尝试她终于来了，我告诉她我感觉她对我有一种无法理解的抗拒，这让我感到困惑和难过。我发誓，那一刻就像是我们两个人的一个压力释放阀被打开了。她告诉我她也有同感，我们基本上发现，我们在初次见面时都倾向于模仿其他人的能量。我想我们当时都在捕捉彼此的犹豫或
he kind of brushed it off and assured me it wasn't because of any jealousy or past that they had. But as you can imagine, every time I saw her, it was a point of anxiety and really hampered my enjoyment of whatever the occasion was. So this went on for years and one day I decided to invite her over. We had never hung out one on one before and it took a few tries but she finally came and I told her how I felt like there was this resistance from her that I couldn't figure out and how it perplexed and saddened me really. And I swear it was like a pressure release valve just opened up for both of us. She told me she felt the same way and we essentially figured out that we both tend to mirror other people's energy when we meet them. And I guess we were picking up on each other's hesitance or
奇怪的氛围。所以从一开始事情就变得有点怪异。但不管怎样，我们最终因为那件事以及其他许多事情而建立了深厚的感情。我们在某个时刻甚至可能一起哭过。但从那一天起，我们就建立了一种不可思议的联系和对彼此的喜爱，这种感情一直持续到今天。所以，莱斯利，这个故事可以说是倾诉益处的典范了。谈谈与你发生冲突的人表现出脆弱的风险与收益吧。我太喜欢这个了。这太美妙了。有两件事真的让我印象深刻。第一是自我觉察，对吧？“哦，我在这个人身边感觉怪怪的。有什么不对劲，”识别出这一点，而不是把它推到一旁，去识别它。
weird vibes. So things just went wonky from the very beginning. But anyway, we ended up bonding over that and a number of other things. We may have even cried together at some point. But from that day on, we've had this incredible connection and fondness for each other that continues today. So Leslie, that story might be the poster child for the benefits of disclosure. To talk about the risks and benefits of being vulnerable with someone that you are in conflict with. I love this. This is so beautiful. There's two things that really stand out to me about this. The first is the self-awareness, right? The, ooh, I feel weird around this person. There's something, right? Identifying that instead of brushing it to the side, identifying it.
第二件我喜欢的事是倾诉的性质，它是一种元倾诉。就像是，“什么，我有这种感觉，这是怎么回事？”而且，现在，你把那个人拉进了一个共同解决问题的任务中，对吧？所以它不是那种“你这样，我那样，我们怎么不同”的对抗。这里的框架让整件事变成了合作性质的，这非常美妙。但你可以想到那些透露自己敏感事情的例子，比如政治倾向——我想到了我的亲戚，我们有不同的政治倾向。这些对话很容易产生冲突。但后来我学到的是，如果你能真正从好奇心的角度去接近他们，
The second thing I love about it is the nature of the disclosure, it's a meta-disclosure. It's like, what, like, I'm feeling this thing. What is it? And it's kind of, now, you're engaging that person in a joint problem-solving task, right? So it's not, it's not like a, you're like this and I'm like this and how are we different. The frame there is making the whole thing collaborative, which is very beautiful. But you can think of like revealing sensitive things about yourself, like political affiliation and like I'm thinking of my in-laws where we have different political affiliations. And it can easily be conflictual these conversations. but what I've learned is that if you can actually approach them from a lens of curiosity,
真正的纯粹好奇心，我们仍然意见不一，但我能更好地理解，也能更多地产生共鸣。所以如果你能达到那一点——这需要练习，我认为。我发现这确实需要练习。正如我们一直在说的，被真正理解你是谁，是建立连接的关键部分。我还想说，当你在描述这个时，我想到了一个轶事。我父亲最伟大的时刻之一。当我们还是孩子的时候，我父母办过无数次晚宴，其中有一次晚宴，我只记得这个，因为我坐在另一个房间看电视，然后气氛变得非常激烈。他们在争论。我甚至不记得他们在争论
like real curiosity, we still disagree, but I understand better and I empathize more. And so if you can get to that point, which takes practice, I think. I have found it takes practice. And as we've been saying, feeling understood for who you really are is the key part of connection. I also wanted to say, I thought of one anecdote as you were describing this. one of my father's greatest moments. So when we were a kid, my parents had tons of dinner parties and there was this one dinner party. I just remember this because I was sitting in the other room watching TV and things got really heated. They were like arguing. I don't even know what they were
什么。我父亲做的是，他走到唱片机前，播放了——是什么来着？——巨蟒剧团的《我们在争论吗？这不是如何进行争论》。《如何进行争论》？他把音量开到最大，这完全打破了僵局。所以这是那种元评论之一，对吧？它是在对当时的情况进行评论。就像是，“哦，这感觉真的很有冲突感，但我们并不是恨对方，到底怎么了？”当他放那段音频时，就像每个人都突然大笑起来。
arguing about. And what my dad did was he walked over to the record player and he puts on, what is it, Monty Python's, are we having an argument? This is not how to buy an argument. How to buy an argument? and he puts it on full blast and it just completely cut the ice. And so it's one of these like meta comments, right? It's commenting on the situation. It's like, oh, this is feeling really conflictual and we don't hate each other. What's going on? And when he put that on, it was just like everyone burst out and laughing.
诺拉还就我们如何进行这样一场对话提出了一些切实可行的建议，我想播放她与我们分享的内容。当我邀请她来时，我营造了一个特殊的空间，这是我从谈话圈活动中学到的，我们盘腿坐在地板上面对面坐着，手里拿着一个来回传递的谈话物件，我认为这真的有助于树立一个真正倾听彼此、想要修复我们之间裂痕的意图。如果我们只是去喝咖啡或坐在厨房桌子旁，我不敢保证结果会是一样的。所以，莱斯利，你对诺拉使用的这个技巧怎么看？
Nora also had a practical suggestion on how we might go about having a conversation like this. And I wanted to play what she shared with us. When I invited her over, I had created a special space that I learned from doing talking circles, where we sat across from each other on the floor and had a talking piece that we passed back and forth, which I think really helped set an intention of really hearing each other and wanting to heal this thing between us. Like we had just met for coffee or sat at a kitchen table. I'm not sure the outcome would have been the same. So, Leslie, what do you make of the technique that Nora used?
有没有其他类似的技术可以帮助我们对他人更加开放？有的。非常重要的事情是：好好接受对方的倾诉、倾听、进行眼神交流，以及少即是多。你的工作不是去解决问题。通常是去倾听并让他们觉得被听见。为此，你要进行确认，对吧？你要重复他们所说的话。
Are there other techniques like this that can help us be more open with others? Yes. Really important things are receiving the person's disclosure well, listening, making eye contact, and less is more. Your job is not to fix. Usually it's to listen and make them feel heard. And to do that, you validate, right? You say, you repeat back what they're saying.
你说：“我听到你感到很沮丧。这说得通。你会有这种感觉是合情合理的。”像这些事情，我知道这听起来像是治疗师的话术，但这已经通过许多许多的研究证明了：当你接收到别人的倾诉时，确认是你能做的唯一最好的事情。但你也要，你知道的，如果你处于诺拉那种情况，这种互惠原则，对吧？你想要分享你的感受，你也想邀请对方分享他们的感受，你希望像这样来来回回地交流。所以实际上，
You say, I hear you're feeling frustrated. That makes sense. It makes sense that you would feel that way. like those things, I know it sounds like therapy speak, but this has been showed in many, many studies that validation is the single best thing you can do when you receive people's disclosures. But you also want to, you know, if you're like in a just like Nora's situation, this rule of reciprocity, right? You want to, you want to share your feelings and you want to invite the other to share theirs and you want to kind of go back and forth like this. And so really,
这个过程真的非常重要。我的意思是，这是一支双人舞。这就是你想表达的。这是一支两个人的舞蹈。对。完全正确。完全正确，完全正确。是的。莱斯利·约翰是哈佛大学的心理学家。她是《倾诉：过度分享的低估力量》一书的作者。莱斯利，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。本节目由《隐藏的大脑》传媒制作。
the process really, really matters. I mean, it's a dance. That's what you're saying. It's a two-person dance. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly, exactly. Yeah. Leslie John is a psychologist at Harvard University. She is the author of Revealing the Underrated Power of Oversharing. Leslie, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你喜欢今天的对话，请不要把它当成秘密。请把它分享给一些朋友、家人或同事。口碑推荐真的能帮新听众找到这个节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. If you enjoyed today's conversation, don't keep it a secret. Please share it with a few friends, family members, or co-workers. Word of mouth recommendations really help new listeners find the show. I'm Shankar Vedantham.
我们很快再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。